MORNING EVERYBODY WELCOME TO
THE APRIL FIFTEENTH- HEARING OF
THE ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE. WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN
AS A SUB COMMITTEE OF MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ARE MONITORING
THIS HEARING FROM THEIR OFFICES
PLEASE COME TO ROOM FOR THIRTY
SEVEN TO THAT WE CAN ESTABLISH
A QUORUM. WE SEEK TO PROTECT
THE RIGHTS OF ALL WHO
PARTICIPATE IN THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS SO THAT WE CAN HAVE
EFFECTIVE DELIBERATION AND
DECISIONS ON THE CRITICAL
ISSUES FACING CALIFORNIA. DO
THE COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC WE
HAVE LIMITED SPACE FOR THE
PUBLIC TO PARTICIPATE SO WE CAN
ENSURE EVERYONE MAINTAIN SIXTY
TO SOCIAL DISTANCE. THIS YEAR
PROTESTERS WHO APPEAR TO
LEGISLATIVE HEARINGS REMOVING
THEIR MASKS. YELLING FROM THE
AUDIENCE AND ISSUING VEILED
THREATS ABOUT POTENTIAL GUN
VIOLENCE. AS WE PROCEED WITH
THE WITNESSES AND PUBLIC
COMMENT. ON A MAKE SURE
EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS OF THE
ASSEMBLY HAS RULES TO ENSURE WE
MAINTAIN ORDER AND RUN AN
EFFICIENT FAIR HEARING. REPLY
THE- WE APPLY THESE RULES. TO
ALL PEOPLE WHO PARTICIPATE IN
OUR PROCEEDINGS. IN ADDITION
THIS YEAR WE WILL AGAIN BE
COMPLYINGWITH ALL PUBLIC
HEALTH ORDERS ARISING OUT OF
THE CUPBOARD NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
IN ORDER TO FACILITATE THE GOAL
HEARING AS MUCH FROM THE PUBLIC
WITHIN THE LIMITS OF OUR TIME.
WE WILL NOT PREDICT CON WE WILL
NOT PERMIT. CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDE THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
LEGISLATIVE PROCEEDINGS. WE
WILL NOT ACCEPT DISRUPTIVE
BEHAVIOR OR BEHAVIOR THAT
INCITES OR THREATENS VIOLENCE.
EVEN VEILED THREATS. AS YOU
CAME INTO THE HEARING TODAY.
THE SERGEANTS DIRECTING YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE RULES FOR
PUBLIC ATTENDANCE AND
PARTICIPATION. WHICH WERE
POSTED OUTSIDE THE DOOR. THE
RULES FOR TODAY'S HEARING
INCLUDES WEARING A MASK OVER
YOUR MOUTH AND NOSE AT ALL
TIMES IN COMPLYING WITH
PHYSICAL DISTANCING NO TALKING
ALLOWED NOISES FROM THE
AUDIENCE. PUBLIC COMMENT MAY BE
PROVIDED ONLY AT THE DESIGNATED
TIME AND PLACE AND AS PERMITTED
BY. ME THE CHAIR OR MR SAY
ORDER WHEN HE IS THE CHAIR.
PUBLIC COMMENT MUST RELATE TO
THE BILL BEING DISCUSSED. NO
ENGAGING IN CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDE THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
THIS HEARING PLEASE BE AWARE
THAT VIOLATIONS OF THESE RULES
MAY SUBJECT YOU TO REMOVAL OR
OTHER ENFORCEMENT. PROCESS THE
COMMITTEE HAS ELEVEN BILLS ON
ITS AGENDA TODAY. AND THE
HEARING HAS A HARD STOP AT ONE
THIRTY PM. IN ORDER TO ALLOW
TIME FOR THIS HEARING ROOM TO
BE CLEANED BEFORE ANOTHER
HEARING IN THIS ROOM LATER THIS
AFTERNOON. GIVEN THE TIME
CONSTRAINTS WILL NEED TO LIMIT
PUBLIC TESTIMONY AS FOLLOWS.
WILL BE A MAXIMUM OF TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
EACH BILL AND TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. TO
EACH BILL. WITH A LIMIT OF. TWO
MINUTES PER PRIMARY WITNESS.
WITH A LIMIT OF THREE MINUTES
PER PRIMARY WITNESS AFTER WE
HAVE HEARD FROM THE PRIMARY
WITNESS THE PUBLIC WILL HAVE
TEN MINUTES IN TOTAL FOR
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT
STARTING WITH THOSE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WERE HERE IN THE
ROOM. THESE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WILL BE LIMITED TO
PROVIDING THEIR NAME OF THE
ORGANIZATION THEY REPRESENT IF
ANY IN THE POSITION. ON THE
BILL. ADDITIONAL COMMENTS WILL
BE RULED OUT OF ORDER I'M GOING
TO BE A REAL. STICKLER FOR
THESE TIMES SO I APOLOGIZE IN
ADVANCE TO EVERYONE I CUT OFF.
I DID NOT MAKE THE DECISION TO
OPPOSE THESE COMPLIMENTS
LIGHTLY. HOWEVER GIVEN THE
LIMITED AMOUNT OF TIME THAT
THIS COMMITTEE HAS FOR
HEARINGS. WITH THE ONLY WAY
THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO
SCHEDULE PUBLIC HEARINGS ON
MORE THAN A SMALL NUMBER OF
BILLS. IN THE COMMITTEE'S
JURISDICTION THIS YEAR. IF YOU
WERE UNABLE TO GET THROUGH ON
THE PHONE PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
SUBMIT WRITTEN TESTIMONY.
THROUGH THE PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE THIS
WRITTEN TESTIMONY WILL BECOME
PART OF THE OFFICIAL RECORD. OF
THE BILL. WE ARE ALMOST DONE.
FOR THOSE WHO ARE WATCHING THIS
HEARING REMOTELY AND WHO WISH
TO CALL IN TO REGISTER THEIR
POSITION. THE CALLING NUMBER
FOR THIS HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN AGAIN EIGHT SEVEN
FIVE SEVEN.AN ACCESS CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. AGAIN ACCESS CODE IS ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR. THREE
SEVEN. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ON YOUR TV OR COMPUTER
SCREEN. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE AS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST IN YOUR
SMART DEVICES. TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTORTION. IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL THE COMMITTEE AT.
916-319-2094 AGAIN THAT'S NINE
ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE TWO
ZERO NINE FOUR AND MY STAFF
WILL BE THERE TO TRY TO HELP.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US AS
WE IMPLEMENT METHODS TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. WILL ALSO BE MY
PHONE RESPECTFUL OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CONCERNS. WE FACE.
BEFORE PROCEED TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS- MADAM SECRETARY
IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE A QUORUM
CAN YOU PLEASE. CALL TAKE
ROLLER CALL THE ROLL. BERMAN
HERE BERMAN HERE SAY OCTOBER
THEY ARE STILL HERE BENNETT.
BENNETT HERE LOW. MAYES MULLIN
BLANCA RUBIO RUBIO HERE AND I
WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME IS RUBIO
I THINK WE MIGHT HAVE A HEARING
EARLIER ON SOMETHING OR OTHER
BUT DIS AND MIS RUBIO IS NEW TO
COMMITTEE AND I'M VERY EXCITED
TO HAVE HER ON MISTER SEA ARGO
IS A NEW MEMBERS OBVIOUSLY NEAR
THE COMMITTEE- AND IS VICE
CHAIR AND EXCITED TO SERVE WITH
HIM WE'RE NOT DONE THIS AT A
PRIOR HEARING I DON'T REMEMBER.
THERE WE GO THERE WE GO. BEFORE
WE PROCEED TO OUR AGENDA I'VE
ONE ADDITIONAL ANNOUNCEMENT TO
MAKE AND A NUMBER TO AB TWO
TWENTY SEVEN AT BY SOMEONE OVER
DAVIES HAS BEEN PULLED FROM THE
COMMITTEE'S AGENDA TODAY AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR WITH ALL
THOSE AMENDMENTS OUT OF THE WAY
WILL NOW MOVE ON THE
COMMITTEE'S AGENDA- BEFORE WE
GET TO THE BILL'S OUR FIRST
ORDER OF BUSINESS WILL BE TO
ADOPT COMMITTEE RULES FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
WITH. LEGISLATIVE SESSION THE
PROPOSED COMMITTEE RULES ARE
SIMILAR TO THE RULES USED FOR
THE LAST SEVERAL SESSIONS. WITH
SEVERAL TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING
CHANGES ADDITIONALLY THESE
PROPOSED RULES INCLUDED A NEW
RULE THAT REQUIRES AN AUTHOR OF
A SPOT BILL. THAT IS PENDING OR
FOR ALL OF THE RULES COMMITTEE
TO PROVIDE THE COMMITTEE WITH
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS WHEN THEY
ARE PROVIDED FOR THE RULES
COMMITTEE. DO WE HAVE A MOTION
TO APPROVE THE PROPOSED
COMMITTEE RULES. GOT A MOTION
AND A SECOND. NOW I'M SECRETARY
WE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BERMAN
HI BERMAN I SAY ARE TOO HIGH.
C. ARCHER I BENNETT. BENNETT I
LOW. MAYES MULLIN. BLANCA
RUBIO. BLANCA RUBIO HI. THE
ROAD IS FOUR TWO ZERO IN THE
COMMITTEE RULES ARE ADOPTED BUT
WE'LL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR.
ABSENT MEMBERS. AS AN EXAM OF
BUSINESSES TAKE OF THE
COMMITTEE'S CONSENT CALENDAR
THERE THREE BILLS N THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THOSE BILLS
ARE ITEM NUMBER THREE. AB THREE
NINETEEN BY SOME MEMBER VALID
THERE IS. A NUMBER FIVE EIGHTY
NINE SEVENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THREE OF US TO BE AMENDED IN THE
ANALYSIS. AND ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY NINE BY
SOMEONE NUMBER LOW. AS PROPOSED
TO BE AMENDED IN THE ANALYSIS.
DOES ANY MEMBER. WAS TO REMOVE
AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. OKAY ME THIRTEEN
SEVENTY NINE. AM I MISSPOKE- IN.
OKAY I JUST. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR CATCHING THEM
BUT- VICE YOU'RE SMARTER TO
THIRTEEN SIXTY SEVEN ALL RIGHT
THIRTEEN SIXTY SEVEN BY SOMEONE
NUMBER LOW THAT'S PROPOSED TO
BE AMENDED IN THE ANALYSIS DOES
ANY MEMBER WITH TO REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SCHERING IN HEARING NONE DO YOU
HAVE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. GOT A MOTION AND
SECOND. NOW I'M SECRETARY WE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL BERMAN HI
BERMAN I SAY OUR CHAU RIGHT NOW
TO AYE BENNETT BENNETT I LOW
MAYES MULLIN BLANCA RUBIO
BLANCA RUBIO I THAT IS THE
CONCERN CONNORS OUT FOR- WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS- WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
OTHER BILLS ON THE COMMITTEE'S
AGENDA THE FIRST ITEM ON TE
AGENDA IS. A. B. FORTY FIVE
SOMEONE NUMBER GONZALEZ THANK
YOU FOR BEING WITH US. PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AB FORTY WOULD REQUIRE
SLATE MAILERS TO INCLUDE
ADDITIONAL DISCLOSURES TO HELP
VOTERS MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS
AND INCREASE TRANSPARENCY. IN
THIS PAST ELECTION WE ALL
HEARD- UNIQUE PROBLEMS WE'RE
FACING WITH WHITE MAILERS AND I
EVEN BROUGHT. ONE IF IT'S OKAY
WITH THE CHAIR- SHE IS A PROP.
THAT WAS SENT TO MY HOME. AND
IT WAS FOR US AS ANOTHER
CANDIDATE AGAINST MY MER- BUT
IF YOU CAN SEE IT IT ACTUALLY
LOOKS JUST LIKE A MAIL PIECE-
WITHOUT ANY INFORMATION ABOUT
WHO IS PAYING FOR THE SENATE
MAIL PIECE WE USUALLY KNOW. BUT
INSTEAD THE SAYS THE VOTER
EDUCATION COALITION DEMOCRATS
FOR REFORM THE GROUP THAT FROM.
FROM WHAT I CAN TELL DOESN'T
REALLY EXIST EXCEPT FOR IN AN
EFFORT TO DO- WHAT IT IS NOT NO
LONGER WHAT USED TO BE A SLIGHT
MAIL PIECE NOW LOOKS LIKE A
TRADITIONAL MAIL PIECE BUT NOT.
DISCLOSE WHO THE FUNDERS ARE.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE STATE
MAIL TO INCLUDE HOW MUCH WAS
PAID FOR CANDIDATE OR BALLOT
MEASURE TO APPEAR ON THE MAILER
AND HOW MANY MEMBERS THE SLATE
MAIL ORGANIZATION REPRESENTS.
SLATE MAIL IS A COMMON SIGHT TO
ALL OF US IN CALIFORNIA VOTERS.
DURING THE ELECTION PROCESS.
BUT SOME OF THESE JUST HAVEN'T
BEEN HONEST IN SOME CASES
CANDIDATES LISTED ARE PORTRAYED
ON SLATE MAILER MAY NOT SUPPORT
THE OTHER POSITIONS TAKEN ON
THE MAILER. IN OTHER CASES THE
POSITION OF INDIVIDUALS THAT A
VOTER MIGHT ASSUME THE SLATE
MAILER REPRESENTS MADE ONLINE
WITH THE POSITIONS TAKEN BY THE
FLIGHT MAILER. AND THIS PAST
NOVEMBER THE COPS VOTER GUIDE
FOR EXAMPLE SLATE MAILER LISTED
AND OPPOSE POSITION ON A
PROPOSITION THAT MANY LAW
ENFORCEMENT ORGANIZATIONS WERE
ACTUALLY. IN SUPPORT OF IN FACT
I THINK ALL LAW ENFORCEMENT
ORGANIZATIONS WERE IN SUPPORT
OF- BUT THEY RECEIVED A
CONTRIBUTION FROM THE
PROPOSITIONS UP HOME.
OPPOSITION CAMPAIGN AND LISTED
IT AS SUCH. I'M DESPITE ITS
NAME THE COPS VOTER GUIDE DID
NOT ACTUALLY REPRESENT ANY
MEMBERS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
ORGANIZATIONS. WHILE WE'VE MADE
IMPROVEMENTS OVER THE YEARS
CURRENT REQUIREMENTS FOR SLATE
MAIL STILL OUT FOR LACK OF TRUE
TRANSPARENCY AROUND WHO IS
SENDING THE SLATE MAIL AND
WEISSERT CANDIDATES ARE BALLOT
MEASURES ARE INCLUDED. THIS CAN
LEAD VOTERS TO BE DECEIVED ARE
CONFUSED ABOUT THE POSITIONS
TAKEN AB FORTY WOULD REQUIRE
THAT EACH CANDIDATE OR BALLOT
MEASURE THAT. IS PAID TO APPEAR
ON THE MAILER. THE TOTAL AMOUNT
PAID BE DISCLOSED DIRECTLY
BELOW THE NAME OR MEASURE NAME
AND POSITION. THE BILL WOULD
ALSO REQUIRE THE NUMBER OF
MEMBERS REPRESENT BY SLATE MAIL
ORGANIZATION OR COMMITTEE TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE NOTICE TO
VOTERS. IN CASES WHERE THE
FLIGHT NOW REASONABLY APPEARS
TO REPRESENT AN ORGANIZATION
GROUP OR CLASS OF PEOPLE. SUCH
AS TEACHERS ARE VETERANS THE
BILL WOULD SPECIFY THE NUMBER
OF MEMBERS WAS. AS THE NUMBER
OF INDIVIDUALS IN THE
ORGANIZATION GROUP OR CLASS WHO
MEET CERTAIN CRITERIA. THESE
CRITERIA. YET SUCH AS BEING
ABLE TO VOTE WITHIN THE
ORGANIZATION ARE PAYING DUES.
AND THE REQUIREMENT TO DISCLOSE
THE NUMBER OF MEMBERS IT'S
SIMILAR TO WHAT ALREADY EXISTS
FOR SLATE MAIL PURPORTING TO
REPRESENT PUBLIC SAFETY
PERSONNEL. THE THAT DISCLOSURES
WILL HELP BETTER INFORM. VOTERS
ON THE ENTITY SPEAKING THROUGH
THIS WHITE MALE WHO'S PAYING
FOR IT WHO STANDS TO BENEFIT.
AND I'D HELP PEOPLE MAKE
DECISIONS ON ELECTION DAY. I
HAVE NO WITNESSES. BUT I
RESPECTFULLY AS FOR AND I
ABOUT. I THINK. WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO- THERE THERE ARE
NO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
SO WE WILL. MOVE ON TO THE
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. AS A REMINDER EACH
PRIMARY WITNESS HAS A MAXIMUM
OF THREE MINUTES YOU DO NOT
NEED TO USE ALL THREE MINUTES-
AND I BELIEVE OUR FIRST PRIMARY
WITNESS- WELL OUR PRIMARY
WITNESSES OPPOSITION EARLIER
LEVINE. OR LEVINE. AND GABRIEL
FOR A WHILE NOW. WHO ARE
TESTIFYING OVER THE PHONE SO
FOR THOSE FOLKS ARE ONLINE
PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU ARE
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN BERMAN
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND STAFF
MY NAME IS LARRY LEVINE. I
APPEARED IN OPPOSITION TO AB
HOLIDAY. THE ISSUE REYES BUT
THIS BILL HAS BEEN LITIGATED
BEFORE AND WAS RULED
UNCONSTITUTIONAL A JUDGE
LAWRENCE CALLED HIM. IN A
LAWSUIT CONTESTED IN FEDERAL
COURT IN SACRAMENTO. YEAH
LEVINE B. THREE OUR CALIFORNIA
STATE ATTEMPTED TO COMPEL THE
PRINTING OF DOLLAR SIGNS NEXT
TO THE NAMES OF CANDIDATES AND
BALLOT MEASURES THAT CHOSE TO
ADVERTISE ON SLATE MAIL. JUDGE
CARLTON FOUND THAT STRAIGHT
MALE IS NO MORE CORRUPTED. MORE
COLLECTIBLE THAN. OTHER FORMS
OF POLITICAL FIGURE. A LOT. OF
LICENSE OF CORRUPTION THE
REMEDY WE NEED TO BE A LEASE
WISH NAY. THE G. YOU HAVE THAT
TO COMPEL SPEECH OF COURSE DOWN
SOMEONE'S HIS NOT THE BUILDINGS
RESTRICT. AND IN FACT- WE WOULD
CALL CAST A NEGATIVE LIGHT ON
THE MAILER. IN ADDITION COURT.
THE REQUIRE EXCEEDED THE
STATE'S LEGITIMATE NEED FOR
DISCLOSURE AND THAT THE CURRENT
REQUIREMENTS OF MASTERS ALONG
WITH EXISTING DISCLAIMERS AND
FILING FINANCE REPORTS ARE
SUFFICIENT TO MEET THE STATE'S
NEED. CALL CAN ALSO TURN ON
THAT SINGLING OUT MALE AMONG
ALL OF POLITICAL COMMUNICATION
IS PROOF OF ANIMUS AND THAT BY
ITSELF. SUFFICIENT GROUNDS TO
ENJOY. AB FORTY REPEAT SAID
ANALYST BY APPLYING ITS
REQUIREMENTS ONLY TWO SLATES
AND NOT TO ANY OTHER FORM OF
POLITICAL COMMITTEE DRUG
COMMUNICATION. I WANTED. ARE
YOU ARE YOU STILL THERE
MICHELIN. OKAY WELL MOVE ON I'M
IS GONNA END OF MISS LIVING
COMES BACK HE'LL HAVE ONE MORE
MINUTE- TO FINISH HIS TESTIMONY
BUT IT SOUNDS LIKE WE LOST AND-
SURE GOOD MORNING CAN YOU HEAR
ME MR I CAN. OKAY GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND STAFF MY NAME IS
GOT IT WHETHER I'M A TRUSTEE OF
THE LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT AND WILL BE A
CANDIDATE FOR REELECTION IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THERE ARE
THREE MILLION REGISTERED VOTERS-IN OUR COLLEGE DISTRICT AS A
CANDIDATE I LEARNED IT WOULD
COST MORE THAN SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND THE CENTERPIECE OF
CAMPAIGN MAIL TO THE HOME OF
EVERYBODY TEACHER VOTER IN THE
DISTRICT. ELLIE TO ATTEND WITH
ME COLLEGES TRICK THAT'S MORE
THAN THE COMBINED AMOUNT RAISED
BY ALL FORTY DOUBLE CANDIDATE
FOR TRUSTEE IN THE NOVEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY ELECTION. IT IS
EVEN WORSE FOR JUDICIAL
CANDIDATE AND THAT LAKE COUNTY
WITH THERE ARE FIVE POINT SEVEN
MILLION REGISTERED VOTERS THE
COP THE MAILING TO EACH OF
THEIR HOUSEHOLD WHICH EQUIPS
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
GIVEN THE IN THE MAIL THESE
NUMBERS PLATE MAIL BECOME AN
ESSENTIAL INGREDIENT
INGREDIENTS IN OUR CAMPAIGN.
THE SAME IS TRUE OF LARGE
DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
A COUNTY WIDE JUDICIAL RICH
JUDICIAL RACES BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS PARK DISTRICT
TRANSIT DISTRICT SCHOOL BOND
MEASURE THAT AFFECTS FOR THE
REQUIREMENT OF EIGHTY FORTY
WOULD DEPRIVE ME AND THOUSANDS
OF OTHER CANDIDATE OF THE USE
THE PLATE MAIL AS A COST
EFFECTIVE MEANS BY WHICH WE
COMMUNICATE WITH VOTERS. THE
INCLUSION OF DOLLAR AMOUNT NO
MATTER HOW NOMINAL IN AND OF
ITSELF WOULD BE BUT WHAT BY
VOTERS AGAIN THAT I BELIEVED
THAT FLORENCE CARLTON MADE THAT
DETERMINATION ENJOINING
ENFORCEMENT UP TO PREVIOUS
ATTEMPTS TO IMPOSE THE SAME
KIND OF REQUIREMENT MONTHLY
MAIL HE FOUND THE CURRENT
DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS
ADEQUATE TO SERVE THE STATE.
INTEREST I RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOU TO DEFEAT EIGHTY FORTY AND
PRESERVE THE INTEGRITY OF THIS
VITAL MEANS OF COMMUNICATING
WITH VOTERS THANK YOU AND HAVE
A GOOD DAY THANK YOU. MR RANA
AND- WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
ADDITIONAL WHEN THIS INTO. OR
ON. TO IT FORTY AS A REMINDER
DO TIME OF. FOR THE COMMITTEE'S
HEARING TODAY THE PUBLIC ONE OF
TEN MINUTES IN TOTAL FOR
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT ALL
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES ARE
LIMITED TO PROVIDING THEIR
NAME. THE ORGANIZATION OF THE
REPRESENT IF ANY IN THE
POSITION ON THE BILL. WILL
START HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
ROOM WHICH IS TO PROVIDE A
POSITION ON AB FORTY SEEING
NONE. ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
OF THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION
TO PROVIDE THE POSITION ON AB
FORTY SEEING NONE. WE WILL NOW
OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WHO WISH
TO PROVIDE THE POSITION ON A.
B. FORTY. MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY ON THE LINE WHO WISHES
TO SPEAK EITHER IN SUPPORT OF
OR OPPOSITION TO AB FORTY. LA
IN JOHN IF SO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE MOMENT
HERE.
AGAIN IT'S ONE ZERO GIVE
ME JUST ONE MOMENT OUTLINED
HERE. THANK YOU. YOU'RE WELCOME
M. LINE SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH I OPPOSE ABC AB
FORTY. THANK YOU. AND NO
FURTHER PARTY THANK YOU GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEEING AND
HEARING- THERE'S NOBODY ELSE IN
THE Q. ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MISTER BENNETT. I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO LET THE- OF
THE AUTHOR NO I REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS I THINK IT'S
REALLY. GREAT IMPROVEMENT IN
TERMS OF THE SYSTEM THAT WE
HAVE IN TERMS OF INFORMING
PEOPLE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE
U. S. SENATE BUSINESS OUT OF.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONCERNS
ABOUT SLATE MAILERS I TOO CAN'T
STAND THAT. I CAN'T STAND LIKE
MAILING. UNFORTUNATELY IT IS
ONE OF THE THINGS THERE A LOT
OF THINGS IN POLITICS I CANNOT
STAND- BUT- I. THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY OF THE A.
BECAUSE I'VE LOOKED INTO THIS
ALSO OF TRYING TO LIMIT WHAT
THEY CAN DO. IS SEEMS TO BE A
BLOCK WALL AND- AND I'M I'M
CURIOUS WHEN YOU WERE
DEVELOPING THIS- WHAT KIND OF
CONST WHAT DID YOU HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION. WITH A
CONSTITUTIONAL LAWYER ABOUT
WHICH WE IS DOES SO SOME GUY
DRESSED WE ABSOLUTELY HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION WITH PLEDGE
COUNCIL ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE HAVE TAKEN COUNT LIKE MR
LEVINE WAS TALKING ABOUT A CASE
FROM TWO THOUSAND TO THE
CIRCUMVENTING CASE IN BETWEEN
THAT WAS CITIZENS UNITED AND SO
IF YOU LOOK AT MORE. RECENT
CASES IN FACT THE LANDSLIDE
COMMUNICATIONS CASE WHICH
SHOULD BE CONTROLLING NOW IT'S
COME AFTER THE SUPREME COURT IT
WAS ACTUALLY A SUMMARY JUDGMENT
AGAINST THE PLAINTIFF BECAUSE
THEY BASICALLY SAID LIKE LOOK
CITIZENS UNITED SAID THIS IS
ALL- TRANSPARENCY IS GOOD IN
THIS IS IN THAT WAS IN A SLATE
MAIL CASE SO WE THINK- AND
GIVEN WHAT LEAD COUNSEL- WENT
THROUGH WITH IT. THE
INTERVENING CASES SINCE SOME OF
THESE WERE INITIALLY DECIDED.
WOULD- WOULD BE CONTROLLING. I
THANK YOU. ARE YOU GUYS STILL
DOES HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
DELVING INTO. THIS HORNETS NEST
THAT IS SLATE MAILERS- SO THANK
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THERE IS A
SERVER MS RUBIO YES WOULD JUST
FOR CLARIFICATION WE'RE NOT
ELIMINATING THE FLEET MAILERS
YOU'RE JUST REQUIRING
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION I COULD
DO FOR AYE EASE FOR EXAMPLE AND
INDEPENDENT EXPENDITURES NOW
REQUIRE CERTAIN FONT AND TO
DISCLOSE WHO IS PAYING FOR THEM
SO IS THAT BOTH ESSENTIALLY THE
SAME THING THEY WERE DOING WITH
THE SLATE MAILERS EXACTLY
GIVING- THE VOTERS MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT YOU KNOW WHO
IS PAYING FOR IT WHO THESE
PEOPLE ARE. M. AND SO THAT
THEY'RE NOT EASILY FOLDS BY- I
NAME RIGHT WELL I DON'T HAVE
THAT INFORMATION AT THE
FINGERTIPS OF WHO'S PAYING FOR
WHAT YOU GET IN A NORMAL BRIGHT
AND CLEAN WELL AND JUST TO
CLARIFY BECAUSE I THINK ONE OF
THE COMMENTS WHAT MADE THAT
THAT THIS IS THE ONLY WAY THAT
FOR EXAMPLE DALY COMMITTEE
COLLEGE- AND SOME OF THE JUDGES
HAVE THE ABILITY TO ADVERTISE
THAT ABILITY STILL GOING TO BE
THERE THIS IS JUST MORE
DISCLOSURE AND THE AND THE-
VOTER RIGHTS. RIGHT ABSOLUTELY
OKAY. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR- MR LOWE IS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HAVE A WIN
FOR ALSO BRINGING. SOMETHING
SPECIFICALLY FOR US TO TAKE A
LOOK AT- AS THEY REQUESTED TO
SEE WHAT YOU. ARE BROUGHT. UP
WHAT IS WRONG WITH. WHAT IS
THE- HOW MATTERS STAND WHAT
WHAT'S WRONG WITH TRANSPARENCY
DON'T WE WANT MORE TRANSPARENCY
IN OUR ELECTORAL PROCESS AND IT
JUST SEEMS TO BE. THAT THIS IS
A VERY SIMPLE BILL. IT SEEMS TO
BE AND IF YOU LOOK AT THAT
PIECE OF MAIL LOOKS LIKE ANY
OTHER INDEPENDENT SPEND AT YOUR
EXCEPT YOU HAVE NO INFORMATION
ABOUT WHO SENDING IT TO YOU.
WHAT IS THE VOTER COALITION
DEMOCRATS FOR REFORM IN REALITY
WELL I LOOKED IT UP. IT'S SOME
HOUSE IN- UP HERE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AT THE ADDRESS. YOU
KNOW WITH NO INFORMATION ABOUT
WHO. WHO THESE PEOPLE
REPRESENTED THEY REPRESENT
ANYONE THAT IT MIGHT BE LIKE
THREE PEOPLE IN A HOUSE RIGHT
THAT'S- AND SO WE HAVE NO
INFORMATION THAT WE WOULD
TRADITIONALLY HAVE WITHIN I
EAT. AN ATHLETE MAIL PIECES
START TO BECOME MORE LIKE
TRADITIONAL MAIL PIECES. ALL
THEY HAVE TO DO IS SLAP ON FOR
OTHER. CANDIDATES AND SUDDENLY
THEY'RE THERE- EXEMPT FROM THE
DISCLOSURE RULES THAT WE
REQUIRED OF EVERYBODY ELSE AND
WE'RE JUST TRYING TO LINE IT UP
A LITTLE BETTER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND IF IT WHEN THERE'S A
QUORUM OR IF IT'S ALREADY BEEN
COMMITTED OF YOUR DAILY THE
DOLLARS FOR MCCANN'S OF THE
MOTION IN THE SECOND. OKAY
THERE YOU GO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF HIM OF. THEY MISS LOW-
ANY ADDITIONAL. SEEING JUST
WHAT. IT WAS ABOUT PLEASE HAVE
IT AND- THE MAN. OF CITIZENS
UNITED A MINUTE. HAS THIS THAT
THIS. IS THE ONE THING THAT THE
SUPREME COURT SEEMS TO BE
CONSISTENTLY SUPPORTING SO I'M
HOPEFUL THAT OF. THIS WILL
SURVIVE CHALLENGES THANK YOU.
MORE PLEASE. DISPLAY MAILERS AS
I FOUND OUT AS I WENT THROUGH
THE SAME PROCESS OF TRYING TO
DO SOMETHING ABOUT THEM. THEIR
ADVERTISERS. THEY ALL WORK OUT
OF THEIR ONE ROOM HOUSE. THEY
DON'T REALLY REPRESENT AN
ORGANIZATION. BUT THEIR
ADVERTISERS AND THAT'S- THAT'S
WHERE THE ISSUE BECOMES. OF THE
KIND OF CLOUD ITSELF. THANK
YOU. YEAH THANK YOUNG FAMOUS
RUSHER. MICHIGAN'S ALL THE ARE
CLOSE AT THE ADS FOR NIGHTS OUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE'VE GOT
A MOTION GOT A SECOND. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE- I'VE GOT
COMMENTS WELL I APPRECIATE THIS
LEE MILLER'S CAN BE IMPORTANT
AND IMPORTANT LOW COST TOOL FOR
CAMPUS COMMUNITY TO VOTERS I
SHARE THE AUTHORS CONCERNED
ABOUT MISLEADING SLATE MAILERS
AND HOPE THAT THE TRANSPARENCY
PROVIDED BY THIS BILL WILL HELP
VOTERS MAKE MORE INFORMED
DECISIONS FROM RECOMMENDING
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN HI BERMAN
I SAY AUTO NOT VOTING THEY ARE
TO NOT VOTING BENNETT. BENNETT
I LOW HI LOW I MAYES MULLIN
BLANCA RUBIO BLANCA RUBIO I.
FOUR ZERO THAT THE BILL IS OUT
FOUR ZERO WILL KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN HOUSE MEMBERS THANK YOU MS
GONZALEZ WE NEED AUTHORS. WE
NEED AUTHORS CALL MISTER LOWE
IS HERE. PERFECT MISTER LOW YOU
ARE UP THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YEAH I HAVE NO IDEA WHERE YOU
ARE ON THE AGENDA MY FRIEND
NUMBER SIX NUMBER SIX. AB FIFTY
THREE. THERE WITH ME. WORTH
CHECKING THE REST OF- IN THE
HOLIDAY SPIRIT THAT'S RIGHT-
THE FITS- SO THANK YOU MR LOW
FOR PRESENTING ITEM NUMBER SIX
ON THE AGENDA AB FIFTY THREE.
ARE YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES I AM PROUD
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTY
THREE WHICH IS A BI PARTISAN
EFFORT MYSELF AND REPUBLICAN A
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VOEPEL ON HELPING MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE ELECTION DAY
AS A HOLIDAY TO CONTINUE TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO VOTING IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE THANK
YOU MR LOW FOR YOUR BRIEF
PRESENTATION THAT WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON. TO THE PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL IS A REMINDER EACH PRIMER
WITNESS HAS A MAXIMUM OF THREE
MINUTES YOU GET A GOLD STAR IF
YOU DON'T REACH THE MAXIMUM WE
HAVE CHRISTOPHE MAIRE AND JASON
JANET. ON THE TELEPHONE PLEASE-
TESTIFY IN WHICHEVER ORDER YOU
PREFER. GOOD AFTERNOON- GOOD
MORNING TERRY MEMBERS KRISTOFF
MEYER CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES.
EVEN KNOWS BALLPARK TO THE WORK
OF THE COMMITTEE CALIFORNIA
CHEAP 70% VOTER TURNOUT DURING
THE TWENTY TWENTY GENERAL
ELECTIONS. IT SHOULDN'T TAKE
COMPOUND IT CRISES AND
POLITICAL PANIC TO REACH SUCH A
HIGH TURNOUT DECLARING ELECTION
DAY A HOLIDAY IS NOT A PANICCIA
BUT IT WILL COMPLEMENT THE WORK
OF THE LEGISLATURE TO EXPAND
ACCESS TO THE POLLS. AB FIFTY
THREE WILL FREE APARTMENT HERE
TO WORK THE POLE AND TO BE POLL
OBSERVER SOMETHING THAT WOULD
BE A GREAT SERVICE TO OUR
DEMOCRACY AND IT KIND OF
COORDINATED MISINFORMATION.
REGARDING THE INTEGRITY OF OUR
ELECTIONS. THIRTY AT THE
PLANTATION OF ARAFAT AND AB
FIFTY THREE WILL ALLOCATE
ELECTION DAY TO THE RANKS OF
OTHER DATE. WHICH ARE INTEGRAL
TO OUR EVOLVING SOCIETY. BY
OBSERVING ELECTION DAY RATHER
THAN PRESIDENT STATE DURING
EVEN NUMBERED ELECTION YEAR.
THIS BILL WILL HAVE A LOW COST
TO TAXPAYERS. AND CLEARLY NOT
SIMPLY AN ATTEMPT TO SECURE A
PAID HOLIDAY. KAREN MEMBERS
PLEASE CONFIRM THAT DEMOCRACY
IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
PRESIDENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MR MAYOR AND MR CHAN. THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
STUDENT COUNCILS. MODERATOR DO
WE SEE A ADJACENT FAN- ONLINE.
IN A QUICK LOOK HERE ONE MOMENT
THANK YOU. YOUR. GRAYSON I DO
NOT HAVE A DECENT CHANCE I'M
FINE WITH IT IS NOT CLASS HE'S
IN CLASS I HOPE THE TEST IS
GOING WELL- IF HE IS A GOOD
POPS ON WHILE WE'RE GOING
THROUGH THIS BILL PLEASE LET ME
KNOW AND WE'LL MAKE SURE TO LET
MR CHAND. IT TESTIFY IT. HI
PERFECT IN THIS BUDGET. GREAT
IMAGES AND YOU GOT THREE
MINUTES. THANK YOU- OKAY GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MIGHT IN THE STATE SEN
I'M A HIGH SCHOOL SENIOR FROM
ALL HIGH SCHOOL IN SAN
FRANCISCO FROM THE GOVERNMENT
DOCTORS CALL DIRECTOR THE
CALIFORNIA. AND COUNSELED WE
ARE STUDENT LED TO RUN CIVIC.
CENTER FOR DECADES HAVE BEEN
ADVOCATING FOR THE CIVIC GATES
PRINTEMPS OF PUBLIC STUDENTS
PUBLIC SCHOOL STUDENTS. IN THE
K. TWELVE SYSTEM CALIFORNIA.
OUR SPONSOR AB FOR THIRTY. AB
FIFTY THREE WOULD ESTABLISH
ELECTION DAY HOLIDAY FOR
STATEWIDE GENERAL ELECTIONS IN
LIEU OF WASH DAY- FOR
CENTURIES. ELECTIONS HAVE BEEN
A CRITICAL PART OF OUR AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY YET VOTER TURNOUT HAS
FLUCTUATED SIGNIFICANTLY. FOR
VOTERS ONE OF THE LARGEST
BARRIER TO GETTING TO THE POLLS
HAVE BEEN THE FACT THAT
LECTURES ARE HELD DURING THE
DAY ON TUESDAY. AND EVEN THOUGH
AND EVEN THOUGH MANY HAVE TO
JUGGLE RESPONSIBILITIES AT WRK
AND AT HOME. AB FIFTY THREE
SOLVE THE PROBLEM NOT ONLY IN
RECOGNITION OF HOW IMPORTANT
ELECTIONS ARE BUT ALSO
EXPANDING ACCESS ACCESSIBILITY
OF BOATING ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE
WHO WORK IN FLEXIBLE VOTING-
IMPOSSIBLE HOURS. FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF STUDENTS THIS
BILL CRITICAL. SALVAGING
ELECTION DAY OF THE HOLIDAY
WOULD OPEN UP SCHOOL FACILITIES
OTHER EXCEPTIONAL COMUNITY
COLLEGE POLLING STATIONS.
SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE
RESTRICTED IF SCHOOL IS IN
SESSION. FURTHERMORE TAKING THE
DAY OFF- INS FROM CLASS SPARKED
IMPORTANT DISCUSSIONS IN THE
CLASSROOM FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
ABOUT WHY WE RECOGNIZE AND
PROVIDE SPACE FOR STUDENTS TO
DO THEIR CIVIC DUTY AND
PARTICIPATE IN OUR DEMOCRACY.
INSTEAD OF SENDING THEIR KIDS
TO SCHOOL PARENTS CAN TAKE
THEIR KIDS WITH THEM O VOTE
NOT THE SCHOOL SITE AND TAKE
THE DAY OFF TO WATCH THEIR
DEMOCRACY IN ACTION. AT HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENT I'VE ALWAYS BEEN
INCREDIBLY EXCITED TO FIND NEW
WAYS TO GET INVOLVED CIVICALLY.
INCLUDING BECOMING A POLL
WORKER WHICH IS ASSISTING
VOTERS IN ACCESSING FILLING OUT
THEIR BALLOTS. ENSURING A FAIR
ACCOUNT AND BEING PART OF THE
LIFE BLOOD OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
YEAH FIVE MANY OF MY PEERS. IN
THE SCHOOL IN ORDER TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THIS OPPORTUNITY.
MAKING ELECTION DAY A HOLIDAY
WOULD OPEN UP THE SCHEDULE OF
MANY MORE HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
TO VOLUNTEER OF POLL WORKERS-
GETTING CIVICALLY ENGAGED. AND
PREPARING THEM TO BE FUTURE
VOTERS BOB THIS IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT- AS WE TALK ABOUT
OPENING UP NEW POLLING STATIONS
WITH GREATER- CAPACITY- FOR
STUDENTS TO- WORKERS COWORKERS.
YOUNG PEOPLE ALSO IN THE HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM THE CALIFORNIA
WOULD HAVE THE ABILITY TO
MAXIMIZE THE PARTICIPATION OF
ELECTION DAY WAS A HOLIDAY. AT
THE AGE GROUP OF EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY FIVE IS STILL CURRENTLY
SIGNIFICANTLY UNDER REPRESENTED
AT THE BALLOT BOX. THE NUMBER
OF FIRST TIME VOTERS AGES
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FIVE WOULD
SKYROCKET IN RESPONSE TO THIS
BILL. AND THE EVIDENCE IS CLEAR
VOTING IS A VERY A **** WILL
PROCESS. AND STARTING THE
PROCESS EARLY EVEN BEFORE- EVEN
pOF LIKE MYSELF BOB WHO STILL
UNDERRATED. CABIN NORMA'S
BENEFITS IN ENSURING STABLE AND
RELIABLE VOTER TURNOUT. LOOK
FORWARD TO THE DAY. I WILL BE
ABLE TO VOTE AND IF THIS BILL
SIGNED INTO LAW JAIN DIRECTOR
OF FOR HONOR FOR HONOR NO BEARS.
OKAY I WILL CUT IT APPEARED IN
MY VOICE HEARD. I RESPECTFULLY
AFTER EYES I'D LOST HIM THANK
YOU JASON- FOR THE TESTIMONY
AND FOR SERVING AS A POLL
WORKER IN YOUR COMMUNITY- WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL AS REMINDER EACH PRIMER
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION- ARE YOU
FAR WITNESS HAS A MAXIMUM OF
THREE MINUTES AND OUR FIRST
PRIMER ARE ONLY PRIMARY ONE IS
IN OPPOSITION IS CALLING
BRITAIN WITH THE ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROJECT CALIFORNIA.
CALLING PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE%
MEMBERS OF THE LAST TIME THAT
THE I. T. C. H. ARE PRESENTED
TO THE COMMITTEE- SOME
UNINFORMED AND DAMAGING THINGS
WERE ALLEGED ABOUT OUR
ORGANIZATION. BUT A MEMBER OF
THIS COMMITTEE TO WHICH WE WERE
NOT GIVEN AN OPPORTUNITY TO
RESPOND. BEFORE WE MAKE OUR
STATEMENT REGARDING AB FIFTY
THREE I'D LIKE TO TAKE JUST A
MINUTE. AND SET THE RECORD
STRAIGHT YOU. OKAY AGAIN IT
AGAIN IT WORK. IN DECEMBER TWO
CHANCE THE POLITICAL CLIMATE
THAT TIME MADE IT HIGHLY
UNLIKELY THAT A FIVE OH ONE SEE
THREE STATUS WOULD BE GRANTED.
AND YOU TO CALIFORNIA'S GLASS
AND FRIENDLY AND PROHIBITIVELY
EXPENSIVE BUSINESS CLIMATE OUR
ATTORNEYS RECOMMENDED THAT WE
LIKE MANY OTHER CORPORATIONS
NATIONWIDE. INCORPORATE IN
WYOMING AS SO AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE WE CAN GET. ON WITH
OUR BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA AND
THAT BUSINESS WAS AND IS
ADVOCATING FOR FAIR AND HONEST
ELECTIONS IN OUR STATE. OF
CALIFORNIA CITIZENS WE HAVE
EVERY RIGHT TO DO SO. IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN ELECTION INTEGRITY
PROJECT TRANSLATIONS TO THE
ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT
CALIFORNIA. A FIVE OH ONE C.
THREE NON PARTISAN NON.
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC BENEFIT
CORPORATION CONTINUING WITH NOT
ONLY OUR RIGHTS BUT ALSO OUR
DUTY TO FIGHT FOR VOTING
RIGHTS. FOR EVERY CALIFORNIA
CITIZEN AND WE WILL CONTINUE
THAT FIGHT. REGARDING. EIGHTY
FIFTY THREE OF THE ELECTION DAY
HOLIDAY LAW- WE NO LONGER HAVE
AND ALLOW. DAY AN ACTUAL
ELECTION DAY CURRENTLY FOURTEEN
COUNTIES PARTICIPATE IN THE
VOTERS CHOICE ACT MODEL THAT'S
MORE THAN HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTORATE. PROVIDES
A LOT OF AN IN PERSON VOTING
DAYS MANDATED BY LAW. DURING
THE TWENTY TWENTY ELECTION
TWENTY FIVE CALIFORNIA COUNTIES
OPTED FOR SUPER POLLING SITES.
HIS FOR IN PERSON VOTING DAYS
THIS MODEL CONTINUES FOR
SPECIAL ELECTIONS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. IN ADDITION VOTE BY
MAIL BALLOTS ARE CURRENTLY
MAILED TO ALL REGISTERED ACTIVE
VOTERS THIS OBJECTIVELY CREATES
TWENTY NINE DAYS OF EARLY
VOTING FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
STATEWIDE. THE LEGISLATURE
CONTINUES TO PUSH COUNTIES TO
ADOPT THESE ALTERNATE. OF
VOTING METHODS WITH EXTENDED
VOTING DAYS ALL INCLUDE
WEEKENDS BOATING OPPORTUNITIES
TO USE ELECTION CODE FOURTEEN
ZERO ZERO ONE MANDATE THAT
EMPLOYERS PROVIDE- TWO HOURS OF
PAID TIME FOR ELECTORS ELECTION
IN PLACE TO CAST THEIR VOTE.
DECLARING A TRADITIONAL BUT NOT
NOW ARE CARE COLLECTION DAY OF
THE HOLIDAY IS UNNECESSARY
MISLEADING PREVALENCE AND
CONFUSING. CELEBRATING THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF OUR PAST
PRESIDENTS GEORGE WASHINGTON
AND ABRAHAM LINCOLN IS A MUCH
GREATER VALUE TO OUR REPUBLIC
BETTER ANOTHER DAY OFF. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
PERFECT TIMING. SO WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. OR IN OPPOSITION TO
AB FIFTY THREE AS A REMINDER
DUE TO TIME LIMITATIONS FOR THE
COMMITTEE HEARING TODAY THE
PUBLIC WILL HAVE TEN MINUTES
UNTIL TIME FOR ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC COMMENT ALL ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES ARE COMMITTED TO
PROVIDING THE NAME OF THE
ORGANIZATION OF THE REPRESENT.
IF ANY IN A POSITION ON THE
BILL WILL START HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE ROOM WHICH IS TO PROVIDE
THEIR POSITION THAT NOBODY IN
THE ROOM ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES TO THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. TO PROVIDE
THE POSITION ON AB FIFTY THREE.
SEEING THAT NONE. WILL NOW OPEN
THE PHONE LINES FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WHO WISH
TO READ THE POSITION ON AB
FIFTY THREE. MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANYBODY ON THE LINE. WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK EITHER IN
SUPPORT. OR OPPOSITION TO AB
FIFTY THREE AND WE'RE GONNA
KEEP A TIGHT LEASH ON IT NAME.
ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT IF
ANY AND POSITION ON THE BILL
THANKS. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
OF PERSONAL GO TO LINE AT
NUMBER NINETY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
JENNIFER TRANSIT LINES AND
CONSTITUENTS. AND F. AS WELL AS
THE PREVIOUS COWORKER AND I AM
OR EIGHTY FIFTY THREE THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR YOUR OLD LINE OF ONE
OH EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. THERE
ARE MARROW WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
Q. AND ACCESS LINE FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
JENNIFER JOHNSON PARTS ACCOUNT
AREA CODE B. FIFTY THREE THANK
YOU.
NOT A MODERATOR ARE THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES. THERE
IS WE HAVE LINE THIRTY EIGHT.
THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HOW MANY IN THE STORE LIGHTING
ONLINE HE CHAIRED THE UC WE'VE
GOT CAMPAIGN COMMITTEE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION REPRESENT BODY OF
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS ACROSS THE STATE
SYSTEM WE ARE CALLING TO
EXPRESS THE NECESSITY TO
ADDRESS THE TIME VERY REQUIRED
PLEASE GET A STATE YOUR
POSITION ON CELL. CARE EXIST
AND MY FRIEND JUST A POSITION
ON THE- I'M SORRY I DIDN'T. LET
THAT- WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
THREE THANK YOU FOR MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT WE HAVE
LINE EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS LOCAL
STOCK MARKET ON AFFORDABLE
BURKE FOR ALBANY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN THE FIFTEENTH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT IN A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM JENNA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS
IS ERIC HARRISON WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
AND WE STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANKS WE'VE GOT LINED
ONE CHAN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS KENYA'S CAR ON THE
CONSTITUENT FROM ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT THIRTY ONE AND I RIP I
GREW UP WITH THAT JOHN UP AS
WELL AS BEING A POLL WORKER IN
THE PAST AS WELL AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS NOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
HEADLINE ONE FOURTEEN LEASE GO
AHEAD. JESSICA CHRISTOPHER-
TOTALLY DISGUSTED VOTER AYE
OPPOSED STRONGLY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT WE HAVE LINE GIVE ME
A MOMENT HERE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THERE MY NAME IS
MARJORIE GRAHAM AND I AM A
RESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA THIRTY
YEAR RESIDENT AND I'M A PULLED
PORK. AND I FIND THIS A
REDUNDANT UNNECESSARY ARE YOU
CLOSE TO THE BILL MA'AM. AT BY
THE CLOSE IN A THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE ARE MOVING ON TO THE
NEXT WHEN IS PLEASE. THANK YOU
AND THAT WE LINE SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS A
GOOD FOR FROM ALAMEDA COUNTY
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER AND I
OPPOSE AB FIFTY THREE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT WE HAVE LINE
ONE OF THREE. HELLO THREE YEAR
OPENS. HI MY NAME IS OFTEN
ENOUGH TO KERN HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT IN THE BAY AREA AND
THEN ALSO REPRESENTING JENNA
AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT AT
EIGHT P. AT FIFTY THREE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND NEXT WE HAVE
LINE THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CAN THAT IRVINE FROM MARIN
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
FIFTY THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEGATIVE ONE ELEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS MICHELLE
ALLEN SIGNED A CONSTITUENT OF
THE FOURTEENTH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT AS WELL AS WE CAN
IMPORT NUMBER BUT NOT YET READY
TO FIGHT WE'LL DISTRICT
REPRESENTING JOHN UP AND I'M
STRONG IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
FIFTY THREE. THANK YOU. EXCEPT
LINE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RUBINI CHAU PASTOR
COUNTY RESIDENTS I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB FIFTY THREE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. X. WE HAVE LINE
FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FIFTY THREE. LEVINE THIRD NEXT
LINE WILL GO TO ONE NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. KEVIN ANDERSON
ON BEHALF OF SILICON VALLEY
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE ARE
MIDWAY THROUGH OUR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY STAGE. FIVE MORE
MINUTES ON THE NEXT LINE AT
NINE NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU. BUT MORNING- MY NAME
ITSELF TROUBLE PUT. OF THE
BRAND VOCAL STATE AND ON POWER
TO FIFTY. THANK YOU. SIX WE
HAVE LINE EXCUSE ME LINE
SEVENTY SEVEN GO AHEAD. I THINK
THEY HAVE A IN ORANGE COUNTY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB FIFTY
THREE THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE
BLIND ONE FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE FIFTEEN. WHAT TO
ALIGN OF THIRTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ADULT COED MYERS I'M
FROM PLASTER COUNTY AND I
ABSOLUTELY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
HEADLINE NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU. FOR WE'VE GOT
A LINE ONE SIXTEEN PLEASE I HAD.
YEAH THANK THE RANKING-
CALAVERAS COUNTY AND I AM IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FIFTY THREE
THANK YOU. A. B. NEXTWAVE LINE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS GLORIA MATHIS YOU
NOW VENTURA COUNTY AND I AM
STRONGLY OPPOSING SB FIFTY
THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANEXO BLIND FORTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS CHRIS FOSTER
FROM ORANGE COUNTY I'M IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB FIFTY
THREE. THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE
BLIND ONE OH NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS KIMBERLY WELL
I AM THOUSAND STUDENT AT UC
BERKELEY I'M PART OF FIFTEEN
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT DOWN PART OF
JENNA AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
FIFTY THREE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WE HAVE ONE ONE SEVENTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES CLAUDIA
CAN LEARN ABOUT ACCOUNTING
FORMER SCHOOL TEACHER WHO NEVER
UNDERSTOOD ALL ACTION I AYE
OPPOSED AB FIFTY THREE THANK
YOU FOR VOTING THANK YOU. CEMEX
WE HAVE BLIND ONE TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI DRAN REYES
PRESIDENT OF THE WOMEN'S
VOLUNTEERS IN POLITICS AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU.
THANKS WE HAVE LINE ONE OF ONE
OH FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR THE
STOMACH MAN IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. NEXT WE
HAVE LINE TWENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
DEVASTATING FROM SOLANO COUNTY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
UNNECESSARY ELECTION DAY-
HOLIDAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH AB
FIFTY TO. AND NEXT WE HAVE LINE
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FORTY SEVEN. BY THE END. HI
PLEASE GIVE US YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION REPRESENT IF ANY
AND POSITION ON A. B. FIFTY
THREE. WHAT ONE MOMENT HERE.
FORTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. HI
THIS IS A HANFORD BURKE FROM
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB FIFTY THREE THANK YOU.
MEXICO LINE TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD AND- ADJUSTING TO MASTER
PLASTER COUNTY NINE OPPOSED TO
S. B. GARY A. B. FIFTY THREE.
THANK YOU. TEXAS BLIND. ONE
MOMENT HERE ONE EIGHTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS RON
LANDER THE SMALL BUSINESS OWNER
TAKE COUNTY STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
FIFTY THREE THANK YOU WE ARE
AND OUR LAST MINUTE OF PUBLIC
TESTIMONY ON AB FIFTY THREE.
LINE SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SIXTY ONE. IT AT ME YES
YES YEAH YEAH. I STRONGLY
OPPOSE IT AB FIFTY THREE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I THINK I CAN
HELP THANK YOU THANK YOU. THE
NEXT IN LINE ONE HUNDRED PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES THERE'S A VAL
MORGAN OF DISTRICT JAN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB FIFTY THREE
THANK YOU AND MOVING ON TO OUR
LAST. WITNESS TESTIMONY FROM
THE PUBLIC. IT LINE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FORTY I'M A
DEMOCRAT FROM KLAMATH
CALIFORNIA WILL OBSERVER
ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT AND
I OPPOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO
THAT CLOSES ARE- TEN PLUS
MINUTES OF PUBLIC TESTIMONY ON
AB FIFTY THREE A REMINDER TO
FOLKS THAT YOU CAN SUBMIT YOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION FOR BILLS
THROUGH THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
I WOULD LIKE TO NOW BRING IT
BACK TO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
OR MOTIONS OR SECONDS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS TO
MOTIONS OR SECONDS. GOT A
MOTION GOT A SECOND COMMENTS
PLEASE WRITE YOUR QUESTION. SO
I DON'T THINK IT'S ANY SECRET
IN CALIFORNIA WHERE WE'RE
HEADED WITH BALLOTS ARE GOING
TO BE MAIL IN BALLOTS AND
THEY'RE GONNA BE MAILED OUT
ABOUT THIRTY DAYS BEFORE
ELECTION IN WHICH DAY WE HAVE
THIRTY DAYS OF WHICH TO FILL
OUT OUR BALLOT AND MAIL AGAIN.
BUT THERE ARE PEOPLE HARD CORE
PEOPLE THAT WANT TO VOTE. IN
PERSON. AND TO ACCOMMODATE
THAT- WE HAVE VOTING IN PERSON
THE FIRST FOUR DAYS JUST PRIOR
TO ELECTION WHICH INCLUDES A
WEEKEND SO MANY STUDENTS THAT
WANT TO. ENGAGE IN THE POLL
WORKING PROCESS. HAVE A
SATURDAY AND A SUNDAY THOSE ARE
ALREADY DAYS OFF. TO BE ABLE TO
ENGAGE IN THAT. IF WE ARE TO
ADD ANOTHER HOLIDAY WHICH BY
THE WAY SHOULD BE A COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING THING FOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES WHENEVER YOU'RE
ADDING OR TAKING AWAY HOLIDAYS
ESPECIALLY PAID HOLIDAYS. THOSE
ARE SOMETHING THAT THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINED FOR- SO
DOES DOES GET OUT AGAIN. THIS
IS NO COLLECTIVE BARGAINING BUT
THAT COSTS TAXPAYERS MONEY TO
BE ABLE TO DO SOMETHING IF THIS
WERE TWENTY YEARS AGO- I MIGHT
VOTE FOR THIS EVEN THOUGH I
WOULD HAVE BEEN AFFECTED
BECAUSE WHEN I WORKED ON
TUESDAY I WORK ON TUESDAY. AND
IN THEIR WAYS AND FOR ME TO
VOTE AND I'VE NEVER NEVER
MISSED ABOUT. SO I KEEP. LIKE I
SAID I THINK TODAY'S WORLD THIS
IS UNNECESSARY. WE KNOW OUR
ELECTIONS ARE GOING EVERYBODY
WILL HAVE A PARK IF EVERYBODY
WILL HAVE THE- MORE THAN THE
ABILITY TO VOTE IF THEY WANT TO
VOTE. AND THERE IS NO VOTER
SUPPRESSION IF WE DON'T HAVE A
DAY OFF ON TUESDAY. AND THIS
COST TAXPAYERS MONEY TO BE ABLE
TO DID DID YET PAY OUT ANOTHER
PAID HOLIDAY. FOR THEM- SO- I'M
NOT GOING TO BE SUPPORTING YOUR
BILL- BUT I DO APPRECIATE THAT
HAD LIKE TWENTY YEARS AGO I
WOULD HAVE BEEN ALL OVER IT
BECAUSE- YEAH PEOPLE COULD VOTE
THEN. THANKS. THEME IS RIGHT-
IS A MEASURE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS QUESTIONS. SEEING NONE
MISTER LOWE WOULD LIKE A QUOTE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ABOUT
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
I SUPPORT SIMILAR BILLS BY THIS
AUTHOR IN THE LAST TWO SESSIONS
AND ALL COMMENDED ON HIS
COMMITMENT TO TAKING STEPS TO
MAKE OUR ELECTIONS MORE
ACCESSIBLE TO VOTERS. THE STATE
HAS ALREADY TAKEN A NUMBER OF
IMPORTANT STUFF THE FACILITY
PARTICIPATION BY VOTERS WHO MAY
HAVE DIFFERENT DIFFICULTY
MAKING IT TO THE POLLING PLACE
ON ELECTION DAY AND THIS BILL
SIMILARLY SEEKS TO ENSURE THAT
WORK AND SCHOOL CONFLICTS ARE
NOT BARRIERS. TO VOTER
PARTICIPATION SO I AM
RECOMMENDING SUPPORT MANAGER-
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THE MOTION IS TO PASS IN
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
BERMAN HI BERMAN THEY SAY AUTO
NO SE ARCH- NO BENNETT. BENNETT
HELLO I LOW HI MAIN. MULLIN
BLANCA RUBIO BLANCA RUBIO I.
THE VOTE IS FOUR TO ONE AT THAT
BILL IS WILL KEEP THE OKAY FOR
AN- MEMBERS- DO WE HAVE ANY. WE
WILL WAIT. THIRTY SECONDS
BEFORE ANY ADDITIONAL AND THEN
AND THEN ME YES LIFE IS A
LITTLE COMPLICATED SO I'M
HOPING THAT OTHER PEOPLE SHOW
UP. BECAUSE ONCE I GO AND MAKES
IT HARDER TO GET INSURANCE
COMMITTEE WHEN INSURANCE
COMMITTEE CLOSES. FOR ME TO
VOTE ON THE BILL'S INSURANCE
COMMITTEE. SO IF THERE ANY WITH
A- YOU ARE FOR THE MODEL'S.
REALLY AUTHORS ANY AUTHORS
WE'RE LOOKING FOR- MISTER
MULLIN AND WE'RE LOOKING FOR MR
KILEY. I THINK THAT'S ALL WE'RE
LOOKING FOR THE LOOKING FOR
THAT'S ALL WE'RE LOOKING FOR.
MR KILEY LOOK AT THAT AS IF ON
CUE THANK YOU SIR. SO THEN THE
FIND MY PLACE IN THE SCRIPT-
ROTH. FIFTY FIFTY. SO THE WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO I BELIEVE
THIS IS THE THIRD TO THE FOURTH
ITEM ON THE AGENDA AB EIGHT
SEVENTY ONE BY SOMEONE OR KILEY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US TODAY YOU MAY
PRESENT YOUR BILL. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MISTER VICE CHAIR-
IN EARLY TWENTY NINETEEN
FEDERAL JUDGE WILLIAM ALSUP
SAID THAT THERE IS A VERY CLEAR
CUT PATTERN HERE- THAT PG&E IS
STARTING THESE FIRES WHAT DO WE
DO THAT THE JUDGE JUST TURN A
BLIND EYE AND SAY PG&E CONTINUE
YOUR BUSINESS AS USUAL. AROUND
THAT TIME A WALL STREET JOURNAL
INVESTIGATION FOUND THAT PG&E
CORPORATION KNEW FOR YEARS THAT
HUNDREDS OF MILES OF HIGH
VOLTAGE POWER LINES COULD FAIL
AND SPARK FIRES YET REPEATEDLY
FAILED TO PERFORM THE NECESSARY
UPGRADES. THE NEW YORK TIMES
STORY AROUND THAT TIME
IDENTIFIED AN UNDERLYING CAUSE
IN A STORY HEADLINED AT THE
POLITICAL PLAYBOOK OF A
BANKRUPT CALIFORNIA UTILITY.
THE TIMES REPORTED THE DESPITE
EVIDENCE THAT THE COMPANY WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR REPEATED SAFETY
VIOLATIONS INVOLVED IN DEADLY
WILDFIRES WELL MAKERS IN
CALIFORNIA CONTINUE TO BENEFIT
FROM POLITICAL DONATIONS FROM
THE COMPANY. THE TIMES
CONTINUED PERHAPS NO COMPANY IN
CALIFORNIA IS MORE ENTANGLED
WITH LOCAL DEMOCRATIC POLITICS
THAN PG&E HELLO I WOULD NOT OF
INCLUDED THE- THE PARTISAN-
QUALIFIER. AND- IT CONTINUED
THE CRITICS SAY THAT THERE'S
BEEN A CULTURE OF CRONYISM
BETWEEN REGULATORS. AND THE AND
THE REGULATED. A SUPERVISOR
AARON PESKIN OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
SAID THAT THE THAT PG&E IS
TREMENDOUS POLITICAL INFLUENCE
AT THE STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL
HAS LED THEM TO BELIEVE THAT
THEY ARE ABOVE SCRUTINY AND
REPROACH. IF THE GAS ELECTRIC
SPEND AS MUCH TIME AND MONEY
AND EFFORT RUNNING THE GAS AND
ELECTRIC FACILITIES AS THEY DID
ON POLITICS THEY WOULDN'T BE IN
THIS MESS RIGHT NOW. AS ONE
EXAMPLE AFTER THE SAN BRUNO
PIPELINE EXPLOSION- SENATOR
JERRY HILL. CALLED ON THEN
ATTORNEY GENERAL KAMALA HARRIS-
TO INVESTIGATE ILLEGAL
COOPERATION BETWEEN PG&E. AND
REGULATORS AND- SENATOR HILL
SAID THE RESPONSE WE GOT WAS
THANKS FOR THE LETTER GO AWAY.
FOLLOWING THE CATASTROPHIC
FIRES OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
WILLIE BROWN SAID HE WAS PAID
BY PG&E TO PERSONALLY DELIVER A
MESSAGE TO GOVERNOR NEWSOM
ADDING I HOPE THEY CALL ME
BECAUSE EVERY CALL. GENERATES
AN INVOICE NOW NONE OF THIS OF
COURSE IS UNIQUE TO PG&E. OR TO
UTILITIES. IT'S JUST THE
CULTURE OF THE CALIFORNIA
CAPITAL QUITE FRANKLY. WHAT IS
UNIQUE HOWEVER IS THE UNIQUELY
INTERTWINED RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN UTILITIES AND OUR
GOVERNMENT I WHICH IS SUCH AS
TO. SERVE AS- A COMPELLING
INTEREST. IN COMBAT AND WHAT
THE UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT
HAS HELD TO BE A LEGITIMATE
JUSTIFICATION FOR RESTRICTIONS
ON POLITICAL DONATIONS- WHICH
IS TO STOP A QUID PRO QUO
POLITICAL CORRUPTION. SO THE
BILL BEFORE US TODAY- SIMPLY I
HAS A NARROWLY TAILORED
INTERVENTIONS. IT IT IN ORDER
TO SERVE THAT COMPELLING
INTEREST IT EXTENDS THE
EXISTING BAR ARE ON PUBLIC
UTILITIES FROM MAKING POLITICAL
DONATIONS. TO UTILITIES THAT
ARE BECAUSE I PUBLIC OR THAT
ARE NOMINALLY INVESTOR OWNED%
BUT THAT RETAIN MANY OF THE
DEFINING CHARACTERISTICS OF
STATE POWER. SUCH AS- MINUTE
MAINTAINING MONOPOLIES ON
ENTIRE REGIONS SEIZING PROPERTY
THROUGH EMINENT DOMAIN AND
ENJOYING A FIXED RATE OF RETURN
STATE OFFICIALS IN TURN. ARE
ESSENTIALLY EMBEDDED IN THE
CORPORATE STRUCTURE OFFICIALS
CLOSELY MONITOR CLOSELY CONTROL
PRICES OPERATIONS AND
PURCHASING THIS IS A
RELATIONSHIP UNLIKE ANY OTHER
WITH A NOMINALLY PRIVATE ENTITY
NOW THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
RAISES. SOME FIRST AMENDMENT
CONCERNS APPROPRIATELY- THAT
MUST BE CONSIDERED WHENEER YOU
HAVE ANY RESTRICTIONS ON
POLITICAL ORAL ACTIVITY
ENGAGEMENT OR EXPRESSION. OF
ANY KIND AND I TAKE THAT
PARTICULARLY SERIOUSLY I'VE
AUTHORED LEGISLATION SUCCESSFUL
LEGISLATION HERE TO ADVANCE
FREEDOM OF SPEECH ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES I'M AN AUTHOR OF A CO
AUTHOR OF LEGISLATION THIS
YEAR- TO ADVANCE FREE SPEECH.
ON SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS
NOTHING IS MORE VITAL TO THE
FUNCTIONING OF OUR DEMOCRACY
THAN ROBUST PROTECTIONS FOR
FREEDOM OF SPEECH BUT THE FIRST
AMENDMENT DOES NOT AFFORD
ABSOLUTE PROTECTION THE
POLITICAL DONATIONS. THE
CONTROVERSIAL CITIZENS UNITED
DECISION BY THE US SUPREME
COURT IN TWO THOUSAND TEN DOES
NOT COVER CONTRIBUTIONS. TO
CANDIDATES AS OR AT LEAST IS
NOT A PUT UP A STRIP. BAR TO-
TO REGULATING THEM ADDING MONEY
TO A CAMPAIGN BANKING THIS
COURT OF HELD IS LESS OF AN-
ACTIVITY. BEEN USING THAT MONEY
TO ADVANCE ONE'S OWN MESSAGE
INDEED CALIFORNIA ALREADY
DISQUALIFIED SEVERAL TYPES OF
ENTITIES. FROM POLITICAL GIVING
EVEN AS THEY ENGAGE IN OTHER
FORMS OF ADVOCACY SO LIKE I
MENTIONED BEFORE A PUBLIC
ENTITY LIKE A CITY OR EVEN A
PUBLIC UTILITY LIKES MUD. ARE
THEY CAN HAVE A LOBBYIST AT THE
CAPITOL BUT THEY CAN'T GIVE
MONEY TO CAMPAIGNS AND SAME
GOES FOR NONPROFITS AND
CONGRESS AND OTHER STATES GO
FURTHER. BANNING CONTRIBUTIONS
BY ALL CORPORATIONS LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS NATIONAL BANKS
AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
CONTRACTORS. SEVERAL STATES
INCLUDING MISSISSIPPI ALABAMA
AND GEORGIA SPECIFICALLY BAR
UTILITIES FROM DONATING TO
CANDIDATES FOR ELECTED PUBLIC
UTILITY COMMISSION. THAT
CALIFORNIA DOESN'T ELECTED PC
COMMISSIONERS SO INEQUIVALENT
RESTRICTION HAS TO BE AIMED AT
THE ELECTED OFFICIALS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR
APPOINTMENT. AND CONFIRMATION
WHICH IS TO SAY THE GOVERNOR
AND LEGISLATORS AND EVEN MISTER
MISTER GUY HOW ARE WE GETTING
CLOSE TO A CLOSE- YEAH I GOT
MAYBE. ANOTHER MINUTE LEFT OKAY.
EVEN PG&E IS OWN OPPOSITION
WATER. MAKES THIS POINT IT SAYS
THAT WHILE THE FIRST AMENDMENT
DOES NOT AFFORD ABSOLUTE
PROTECTION TO POLITICAL
CONTRIBUTIONS. COURTS HAVE
DEMANDED THAT LAWS SINGLING OUT
AN INDUSTRY BE NARROWLY
TAILORED FOR EXAMPLE TO INCLUDE
CANDIDATES FOR POSITIONS. THAT
ACTUALLY REGULATE THE
CONTRIBUTOR. AND THAT'S US
THAT'S THE LEGISLATURE THAT'S
THE GOVERNOR WE DO NOT HAVE AN
ELECTED PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION WE HAVE A GOVERNOR
WHO APPOINTS THE COMMISSIONERS
OF THE SENATE WHO CONFIRMS
THEM. OUR LEGISLATURE HAS
COMMITTEES LIKE THE UTILITY AND
COMMERCE COMMITTEE- AND WE VOTE
ON LEGISLATION THAT GIVES THE
UC ORDERS AND COVERS THE SCOPE
OF WHAT IT DOES SO I DON'T
THINK THAT THE FIRST AMENDMENT
CONCERNS HERE- OUGHT TO HOLD
BACK THIS. LEGISLATION AND
ULTIMATELY BORING UTILITY
CONTRIBUTIONS IS
CONSTITUTIONALLY PERMISSIBLE
FOR THE SAME REASON IT IS
LEGISLATIVELY ADVISABLE UTILITY
IS SO JOINED AT THE HIP WITH
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
THE RISK OF UNDUE INFLUENCE.
BOTH THE LIKELIHOOD AT ALL KERR
AND THE HEART OF WHAT IT DOES
IS INTOLERABLE TO THE PUBLIC
INTEREST. AS A WITNESS TODAY ON
THE PHONE LINE I HAVE TRENT
LAYING IT WHO IS WITH THE CLEAN
MONEY CAMPAIGN. AND I'M GONNA
TURN IT OVER MY SISTER. WHILE I
RUN DOWN AND VOTE. COMMITTEE
WHICH IS WRAPPING UP AND THEN
I'LL BE RIGHT BACK BUT WE ARE
IN GOOD HANDS THANK YOU I THANK
YOU MR KILEY WE HAVE HERE A
WITNESS TESTIMONY- GO AHEAD.
YES- GOOD MORNING AT YOUR VICE
CHAIR AND THE MEMBERS TIME
TRAVELING PRESENT IN THE
CALIFORNIA COULD MONEY
CAMPAIGN. I'D LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KILEY FOR
BRINGING FORWARD THIS IMPORTANT
BILL- THE HUGE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT CAN I CAP RATES FOR THEIR
CAMPAIGNS MUCH OF IT FROM VERY
LARGE DONORS IS A CONCERN OF
OURS AND- ALMOST. ALL
CALIFORNIANS. HOWEVER OF THE
FAIRNESS WE DON'T NORMALLY
WEIGH IN ON VANCE ON
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM ONE SPECIFIC
TYPE OF ENTITY OR ANOTHER.
HOWEVER AS ALSO POINT OUT
PUBLIC ENTITIES ARE ALREADY
BANNED FROM MAKING
CONTRIBUTIONS TO CANDIDATES DUE
TO THEIR SPECIAL NATURE. WE
AGREE WITH THE AUTHOR THAT
ELECTRICAL CORPORATIONS AND GAS
CORPORATIONS REPRESENT A
SIMILAR SPECIAL CASE. BECAUSE
THEY ENJOY A STATE SANCTIONED
MONOPOLIES ON ENTIRE REGIONS
THAT ARE UNDER STATE REGULATION
AND CONTROL OVER THEIR PRICES
OPERATIONS AND PURCHASES. ALL
OF WHICH MAKES THE APPEARANCE
OF POSSIBLE INFLUENCE OF
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS FROM
THEM PARTICULARLY HARMFUL TO
PUBLIC PERCEPTION. OF. THE
FAIRNESS OF THEIR OVERSIGHT. A
JUST AS THE- ON OTHER TYPES OF.
CALIFORNIANS HAVE BIRCHLEY NO
CHOICE WHETHER TO PATRONIZE
THEIR LEXICAL AND GAS
CORPORATION. WHY WE THINK THERE
MAY BE GOOD REASON TO LIMIT ALL
TYPES OF CONTRIBUTIONS FROM NON
INDIVIDUALS. PEOPLE CAN AT
LEAST CHOOSE NOT TO PATRONIZE
THE CORPORATION THAT CONTRIBUTE
TO CAN MAKE THAT THEY DON'T
LIKE. BUT THAT'S NOT TRUE THE
MONEY THEY ARE REQUIRED TO PAY
TO STATE SANCTIONED MONOPOLIES
OF THE GAS AND ELECTRICAL
COMPANIES IF THEY WANT TO KEEP
THE LIGHTS ON. FOR ALL THESE
REASONS WE'RE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT AB EIGHT SEVENTY ONE
AND RESPECT RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST DRIVER THANK YOU. THANK
I DON'T THINK WE HAVE ANY MORE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT SO WE HAVE
A ONE WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
SHAUB SHAUB MUHAMMAD. FROM THE
ACCOUNTS CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IS- ARE YOU ON. YES I AM GO
AHEAD SIR. THANK YOU RESPECTED
SURE MEMBER RUNNING SHORT
MUHAMMAD IS BETTER WITH
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND THAT WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
AB EIGHT SEVENTY ONE- EXCLUDING
ALL COMPANIES IN THE SECTOR
FROM PARTICIPATING IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS IT IS NOT A
MEASURE TO OUR FACTORY THE
LESIONS OF THE ISSUES THAT THIS
BILL. INTO ADDRESS AB EIGHT
SEVEN ONE IS PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD THE DENIES
ELECTRIC AND GAS CORPORATIONS
THE RIGHT TO MAKE POLITICAL
CONTRIBUTIONS AND EXCLUDE THEM
FROM THE POLITICAL PROCESS WE
DO NOT BELIEVE THAT THIS IS THE
THIS LIMITED WAY THAT TO SOLVE
THE PROBLEMS AB EIGHT THIRTY
ONE RATE THAT TANGIBLE FIRST
AMENDMENT ISSUES- BY DENYING
THE CORPORATIONS THE RIGHT TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROCESS OF
DIRECT CONTRIBUTIONS TO
CANDIDATES FOR STATE OFFICE.
AND FURTHER BUDGET AGAINST THE
EQUAL PROTECTION CLAUSE BY
CREATING A GOVERNMENT
PROHIBITION ON POLITICAL
ENGAGEMENT ALLOW SPEECH BY
SADDAM BUT THE NINE SPEECH FROM
OTHERS. AB EIGHT THIRTY ONE
ALSO SUPPORT FOR CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM ELECTRIC AND
GAS CORPORATION BESIDES NO
COMPELLING STATE INTEREST THAT
JUSTIFIES THE OUTRIGHT BAN ON
THESE CONTRIBUTIONS FROM THE
CLASS OF ENTITIES BUT WITHOUT
NO WITHOUT A COMPELLING STATE
INTEREST TO DEMONSTRATE HOW
GOVERNMENT THAT ON POLITICAL
SPEECH WITH CERTAIN GROUP ONE
INDIVIDUAL COMPANY PUT THE
PERFORMANCE OR BETTER SERVE THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS IN GENERAL.
ON THE CONTRARY POLITICAL
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM ELECTRIC AND
GAS CORPORATION TO HELP PROTECT
THE INTERESTS OF COULD
CUSTOMERS EMPLOYEES AND OF
COURSE SHALL WHAT SHAREHOLDERS
BY SUPPORTING POLITICAL
CANDIDATES TO SEEK TO
UNDERSTAND THE INDUSTRY AND THE
COMPLEXITY THEM PORTABILITY
ISSUES INCLUDING WHILE BY
MEDICATION INTEGRATION OF
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY SOURCES- AND
TRANSPORTATION AND BUILDING
ELECTRIFICATION. ELECTRIC AND
GAS COMPANIES ARE ON THE FRONT
OF THE MISSION THEY KNOW THIS
INDUSTRY THAT THEY LEAVE THE
DISHES EVERY DAY AND OF COURSE
IT'S CRITICAL BECAUSE THEY ARE
THE ONES WHO ARE BEST EQUIPPED
TO REPRESENT THE INTERESTS OF
THEIR STAKEHOLDERS CUSTOMERS
AND FOLKS ARE CONCERNED WITH
THEIR WITH THEIR SERVICES. THIS
BILL WILL SILENCE THE SPORTS
FROM PARTICIPATING IN THE
POLITICAL PROCESS RESULTING IN
AN UNEVEN NON INCLUSIVE
POLITICAL PLAYING FIELD THAT
AGAIN SILENCE OF THE VOICE OF
SOME PEOPLE AND ALLOWS ALLOWS
VOICES FROM OTHERS A POLICE
REASONS WE MUST GOT INTO
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB. EIGHT
SEVENTY ONE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY. AND I AM LOS IN MY-
AGENDA- PERFECT- ANY WITNESSES
IN THE ROOM SEEING NONE AND
WITNESSES IN THE- ON TV SEEING
NONE. ANY WITNESSES- THE
TELEPHONE LINE MATAMATA READER
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE ENDEAVOR
MINDER- WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES THE BORDER
IN OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT
SEVENTY ONE. AS A REMINDER DUE
TO TIME LIMITATIONS FOR THE
COMMITTEE HEARING TODAY THE
PUBLIC OFF TEN MINUTES IN TOTAL
TIME FOR ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENT ALL ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES ARE LIMITED TO
PROVIDING THEIR NAME THE
ORGANIZATION OF THE REPRESENT
IF ANY. IN THE POSITION ON THE
BILL. NOT A MODERATOR ANYBODY
ON THE PHONE FIVE ONE ZERO. WE
DO HAVE SOME BOB WHITE AND GO
TO LINE ONE FORTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE FORTY FIVE YOUR
LINES OPEN. ONE FORTY FIVE.
LEVINE HERE WE'LL GO TO LINE
SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO YES AND I'D LIKE TO OPEN.
YES MARJORIE GRAHAM
REPRESENTING A WOMAN POLITICAL
GROUP IN SANTA MONICA
CALIFORNIA TWO HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE STRONG WITH. I'M SORRY WE
COULDN'T HEAR YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL. WE SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
NEXT DEADLINE ONE TWENTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
MELINDA WARNER I'M FROM FRESNO
CALIFORNIA AND- WE HAVE SEEN
AGREED TO ALL THESE JUST WRITE
YOUR NAME OR ANY ORGANIZATION
YOU MIGHT REPRESENT AND YOUR
POSITION OF SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION FOR THE BILL.
MELINDA WARNER I AM A FORMER
POLL WORKER AND I AM IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL I LIVE IN FRESNO
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NECKED BOTTLE LYING TWELFTH
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS JUSTIN
MASTERSON POSTURE COUNTY ON IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY ONE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT IN LINE
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
ZERO NINETY HELLO HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN. OKAY GREAT-
I'M L. COMMERCIAL I AM- THE
CONSTITUTION OF RANDY VOEPEL
STILL STRICT AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT WE HAVE LIKE A
ONE THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MARLENA TWO FRAMES FROM SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY AND I'M IN SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHT SEVENTY ONE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT LINE THIRTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOLLOW
MEDICAL MYERS FROM FIVE TO
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY AGREE AND
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO VOTE YES
ON SB EIGHT SEVENTY ONE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND NEXT WE HAVE
LINE FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ROD BREWER WITH
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON FOR
THE REASONS STATED BY A MISTER
MUHAMMAD WE URGE YOU TO VOTE NO
ON AB EIGHT SEVENTY ONE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND NEXT WE HAVE
LINE ONE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS LEONARD H.
PLASTIC KELLY LINDA RICH
PLASTER COUNTY AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. THAT
HASN'T BY ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
AHEAD. YES VAL MORGAN DISTRICT
CAN I SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU. IN FACT WE HAVE NINETY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
QUICKER AVE INTERCOUNTY I
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU.
NEXRAD LINE EIGHTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS JACK WELCOME
SAN MARIN COUNTY AND I AM
STRONG ISSUES WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE LINE
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EIGHTY TWO. BUT WE CAN'T HEAR
YOU. ALL THE- YEAH NEXT TO YOUR
LINE ONE THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I GUESS CAN YOU HEAR ME. YEP
YES WE CAN MY NAME IS AUNT
WROTE AN ORANGE COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. AND NEXT WE HAVE
LINED ONE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JESSICA CHRISTOPHER
RIVERSIDE COUNTY. I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
NEXT WE HAVE LINED ONE FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB EIGHT SEVEN ONE
CRITICAL NHà FROM SPRING
VALLEY CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THREE HOW BLIND ONE FIFTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO COOL
OUR CAMPAIGN- I STRONGLY
SUPPORT MITCHELL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE LINED
ONE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I WOULD ALSO- GOOD MORNING IN
THE SUGGEST CUSTOM- YOU KNOW
HILLS I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TWO
SEVEN EIGHT TWO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND NEXT WE HAVE LINE
SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SEVENTY EIGHT. HELLO WHAT CAN
WE CAN PROVIDE TO LINE ONE
FIFTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
CHAIR CHRIS PATTERSON FROM
PACIFIC GAS AND ELECTRIC IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU. YOU HAVE LYING
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. RON
REFORMERS IT COUNTED FROM THE
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE'RE A LITTLE OVER HALF
WAY THROUGH THE PUBLIC COMMENT
PERIOD. AGAIN IT IS A ONE AND
THEN ZERO OUR LAST TWENTY TWO
AT THIS POINT IS BLIND ONE
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
SUPPORT BILL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANY ADDITIONAL FOLKS ON
THE LINES. NOT AT THIS POINT
ALL RIGHT THEN WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO COLLEAGUES FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS OR
MOTIONS OR SECONDS. A QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS OR MOTIONS OR
SECONDS. SEEING NONE MISTER
COLLEY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE-
YES THANK YOU AND- I FORGOT TO
NOTE THIS IS BIPARTISAN
LEGISLATION UNFORTUNATELY MY CO
AUTHOR MISTER KANSEN CHU HAS NO
LONGER- IN THE LEGISLATURE I
THINK HE'S ONE OF MY SUPERVISOR
NOW SOMEBODY'S NOT EVOLVED
ABOUT ONE NOW ALL RIGHT WELL IN
ANY CASE HE'S NOT HERE BUT HE
WAS. A CO AUTHOR OF THIS
LEGISLATION- AND- IT'S A BILL
THAT I THINK I CAN GO A LONG
WAY TOWARDS. RESTORING PUBLIC
TRUST AND- HOPEFULLY GETTING
US- ON THE RIGHT TRACK- WHEN IT
COMES TO- THE SAFETY OF-
CALIFORNIANS GOING FORWARD SO I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NIGHT
OUT. THANK YOU MISTER KILEY-
AND WE WILL I THINK- MISTER
JONES TO KEEP IT OPEN DO WE
KEEP IT. IN ORDER. OUR MOTION
CAN BE IN ORDER UNTIL THE END
OF THE HEARING SO- WILL HAVE
UNTIL THE END OF THE HEARING
FOR EMOTION IN THE SECOND.
THANK YOU MISTER KILEY THANK
YOU. OKAY SO THAT LEAVES I
BELIEVE MR MULLEN THE BILL'S
AND MY BILLS SO LET'S GIVE MR
MULLIN. THIRTY SECONDS OR SO TO
MAKE IT TO THE- HEARING ROOM
AND IF HE DOESN'T ARRIVE WHICH
I HAVE EVERY CONFIDENCE HE
WILL. THEN I'LL GO. THANK YOU
EVERYBODY FOR BEING HERE. I
KNOW WE ALL HAVE A LOT GOING ON
THESE DAYS. EIGHT THE SEVENTY
THREE. CALIFORNIA. FOR THIRTY
SEVENTY YEAH. THANK YOU BERMAN.
YOUR DATE YET WITH LET'S GIVE
MR MULLIN TEN MORE SECONDS. AND
THEN AND THEN IT WILL BE GO
TIME. LOOK AT BY THE SKIN OF
HIS TEETH. THANK YOU MISTER
MULLIN FOR SPARING ME FOR A FEW
MORE MINUTES. BUT SO- WE WILL
MOVE ON TO A. B. E. L. I. THE
NUMBER EIGHT AB SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
CHAIR MEMBERS AB SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT SEEKS TO SYNC UP THE TIME
LINES. BY WHICH VOTE BY MAIL
GUYS AND COUNTY VOTER
INFORMATION GUIDES ARE REQUIRED
TO BE MAILED OUT TO VOTERS.
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES THE COUNTY
VOTER INFORMATION GUIDES BE
MAILED OUT TO REGISTERED VOTERS
NO LATER THAN TWENTY ONE DAYS
BEFORE ELECTION DAY. WELL THE
ACTUAL VOTE BY MAIL BALLOTS ARE
TO BE MAILED OUT TWENTY NINE
DAYS BEFORE AN ELECTION. WITH
MOST OF CALIFORNIA'S ELECTORATE
CHOOSING TO VOTE BY MAIL OVER
86% OF BALLOTS CAST TO NOVEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY WERE V. VIA
BALLOTS IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE
JUST VOTERS HAVE ACCESS TO.
CRUCIAL BALLOT INFORMATION
BEFORE THEY CAST THEIR VOTE. AS
AN OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIANS CHOOSE VOTE BY
MAIL THERE'S A HEAVY EMPHASIS
ON EARLY VOTING ELECTION DAY
HAS BECOME ELECTION SEASON AS
VOTERS RETURN VIA BALLOTS JUST
DAYS. AFTER RECEIVING VIA MAIL.
WITH THIS IN MIND IT IS
CRITICAL THAT WE ENSURE
NONPARTISAN INFORMATION IS
AVAILABLE AND IN THE HANDS OF
REGISTERED VOTERS BEFORE THEY
GO TO FILL OUT THOSE BALLOTS.
ALTHOUGH THAT WE ARE CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH AND GET FEEDBACK
FROM THE CLERKS AND ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS. THAT WILL BE
INSTRUMENTAL IN IMPLEMENTING
THIS TWO TIME LINES. WITH THAT
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS COMMONSENSE
FIX BOB THIS MAY FALL INTO THE
CATEGORY OF AUTHOR PET PEEVE.
BUT IT IS NOT UNIQUE TO ME HIGH
INCENTIVE COUNTY HAVING
RECEIVED MY VOTER INFORMATION
GUIDE AFTER I RECEIVE MY
BALLOT. THOSE BALLOTS
STATEMENTS WE ALL KNOW COST
MONEY. WE OUGHT TO BE MORE
RESPECTFUL OF THE CANDIDATES
THAT ARE SUBMITTING INFORMATION
TO THE VOTERS AND TO THE VOTERS
THEMSELVES WHO SHOULD HAVE THE
BENEFIT. OF THIS INFORMATION
BEFORE THE CAST. A BALLOT AND
ASPIRIN I BUILT. GOT TO MOST.
AND A SECOND. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER MOLAN. THAT IS SO
WELL NOW SO I DON'T SEE ANY
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION SO WE'RE GOING TO
OPEN IT UP TO WITNESSES- IN.
THE AUDIENCE WILL NOW MOVES TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION OF AB SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT AS A REMINDER DUE
TO TIME LIMITATIONS FOR THE
COMMITTEE HEARING TODAY THE
PUBLIC OFF TEN MINUTES IN TOTAL
TIME FOR ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENT ALL ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES ARE LIMITED WRITING
THEIR NAME THE ORGANIZATION
THAT THEY REPRESENT IF ANY. IN
A POSITION ON THE BILL WILL
START HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM SEEING NONE TAKEN IT OVER
TO THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION
SEEING NONE GOING TO THE PHONE
LINES MADAME MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. OF AB SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT. IT WILL GO TO LINE ONE
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
FIVE SIX. YOUR HEADLINE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
DEBORAH THANK YOU FOR CLAREMONT
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FOR LINE ONE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. KRISTOFF MEYER WITH
THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
AB SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
NEXT WE HAVE LINE NINETY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BUT- BY MALCOLM
MITCHELL I'M CALLING IN FOR THE
PART OF THE BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. PFENEX RAV LINE FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS JENNIFER JOHNSON PLASTER
COUNTY SUPPORT AB SEVEN FRANK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXRAD
LINE SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS GREG POOREST
MELANIE TO COUNTY IN A SUPPORT
AB SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU. NEXT WE HAVE LINE SIXTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
MARJORIE GRAHAM REPRESENTING
THE SANTA MONICA POLITICAL
WOMEN'S ORGANIZATION AT SIXTY
TWO HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE WOMEN.
AND WE SUPPORT THE NO NONSENSE
AB TWO SEVEN EIGHT SEVEN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I WOULD LIKE TO
REMIND EVERYBODY THAT THIS IS
AB SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT TO FIVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN. A BUS
ONLY- AB SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT BY
SOME OF OUR MOMENT THANK YOU.
HAVE LINE NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINETY FIVE. YOUR LINE
NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BURKE OR START OF THE TERROR
COUNTY SUPPORT SEVEN TWENTY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE ONE
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
TWENTY SIX. AN EXTRA LINE OF
FORTY SEVEN. HI THIS IS DAN
FLED BURKE FROM SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY AND I AM SUPPORT IN
SUPPORT OF THE AB TWO TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXTWAVE LINE FORTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
CHRIS FOSTER ORANGE COUNTY.
REPORT AB SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND ACTUALLY WE HAVE LINE
THIRTY SEVEN. THIS IS CAROL
DROP IN PLASTER COUNTY SUPPORT
OF AB SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU. NEXT WILL OPEN LINE. ONE
THIRTY NINE. MARLENA DIFFERENT
AND ANNE AND I SUPPORT. AB
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
NEXT CALL OPEN LINE. ONE
FIFTEEN. ONE FIFTEEN YEAR OPEN.
COMMITTEE ON SITE REPRESENTS
WOMEN VOLUNTEERING CALLER. AND
I SUPPORT A. B. SEVENTY EIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE CAN
OPEN LINE. TWENTY EIGHT. AB
CHANNEL CLATTER COUNTY
RESIDENTS ELECTION INTEGRITY
PROJECT I SUPPORT EIGHTY SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT THANKS. NEXT WEEK
GAP LINE ONE SEVENTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE SEVENTEEN. WE GOT
A LINE OF. ONE FIFTY NINE. WHAT
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
IS THAT MAINTENANCE YES THAT IS
GET YOU. YEAH I WROTE DOWN ONE
FIFTY NINE SORRY THIS IS DENNIS
BEATTY FROM SOLANO COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SUPPORT AB
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THE NEXT RECORD LINE
THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS WAYNE MEYERS FROM
PLASTER COUNTY AND I SUPPORT%
EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. ANNEX HAVE LINED ONE OH
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIR THE SYSTEMIC MANAHAN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NEXRAD LINE ONE THIRTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME HELLO
IT'S NANCY BURROWS AND I AM
STRONGLY SUPPORT EIGHTY SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. HAVE LINE TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
GLORIA MATH TEACHING THERE
VENTURA COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT A. B. SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
EXCEPT NINE NINETY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BINANCE COIN THANK
FROM SACRAMENTO COUNTY I AM
SUPPORT EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU FOR. NEXT
THING ONLINE EIGHTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ZERO ONE WONDERFUL
RIVERSIDE COUNTY HAS STRONG
MEMBERS OF SUPPORT SB SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU. FY ONE
HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT VAL
MORGAN STANLEY I REPRESENT THE
STATE OF JEFFERSON I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB SEVEN TWENTY THANK
YOU. NEXRAD LINE SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SEVENTY EIGHT
STE. KARATANTCHEVA LINE NUMBER
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AND WE'VE GOT LINE ONE
SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO COOL L. A. COUNTY I
STRONGLY SUPPORT. EIGHTY SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. VERY MUCH. WE'RE THREE
MINUTES LEFT IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY. AND AGAINST ONE ZERO
OCTOBER TWO LINE SIXTY NINE.
YES I'M CINDY CUSTER AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB SEVEN TO
EIGHT I'M FROM SAN DIEGO COUNTY
THANK YOU. AN ACTUAL LINE
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINES OPEN. AND
WE CAN GO TO LINE. ONE TWENTY
SIX. BY ONE TWENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I TRY ONE MORE
TIME ONE ONE TWENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN HERE. I RULE. I
NEVER GOT YEAH YOU'RE YOU'RE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN SIR. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO STATE YOUR NAME AND
POSITION ON THE BILL. OKAY
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE NEXT THANK
YOU. SURE SURE AND I WILL GET
LINE PORT WHY ONE FORTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT TWENTY
BALLING IN ORANGE COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU. RIGHT
NOW WE TELL ONE MORE HERE WE'LL
GO TO LINE ONE FIFTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO I AM A CART
MARIN COUNTY HAVE STRONGLY
SUPPORT EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
CURRENTLY NO FURTHER PARTISAN
Q. THREE TO HAVE ONE ONE WITH A
LINE. ONE FORTY ONE FORTY FIVE.
IF YOU ARE IN COUNTY STRONGLY
SUPPORT EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND WE'VE GOT ANOTHER ONE
HERE WE GO BUT WHAT A ONE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES AT GRAND REYES PRESIDENT.
OF THE WOMEN'S VOLUNTEERS IN
POLITICS SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU WE HAVE TIME FOR ONE
MORE IF ONE EXISTS. SURE
ENOUGH. IT WILL GO TO Y. AT
LINE ONE TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CHECK ONE TWENTY SIX
EUROPE LINES OPEN. HELLO THIS
IS TEACHER OPEN FROM PLASTER
COUNTY AND I'M SUPPORT OF AB
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT. NORTH GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO OUR
PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD HAS
CLOSED FOR EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT A REMINDER TO FOLKS THAT
YOU CAN SUBMIT YOUR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION THROUGH THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE WE'RE GONNA
BRING IT BACK TO COLLEAGUES FOR
COMMENTS WE ARE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND VICE YOU'RE SURE
TO. I MISS MULLIN THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS IS A COMMON SENSE
MEASURE TO MAKE SURE VOTERS ARE
INFORMED. I ALSO WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR POINTING OUT THAT IS NO
LONGER LECTION DAVID ELECTION
SEASON TO THE WHERE WERE YOU
TWENTY MINUTES AGO. THANK YOU.
MR MAYS. BUT NOT ONLY- SHOULD
THIS BE MARKED UP AS ONE OF
THOSE BILLS THAT'S THE THAT'S
FROM A PET PEEVE BUT IT'S ALSO
ONE OF THOSE THINGS WHERE YOU
THINK WHY IN THE WORLD WE HAVE
TO HAVE THIS BILL- BUT BECAUSE
I THINK SOME OF US EXPERIENCE
THIS LAST ELECTION SEASON WE
HAD A BALLOT AND HANDED IT TOOK
IT WASN'T JUST A WEEK BUT WAS
EVEN LONGER IN OUR COUNTY-
ANNUALLY AND YOU THOUGHT I'M
IT'S RIDICULOUS SO THANK YOU
WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO ASK IF I
COULD BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR.
ABSOLUTELY THE MEASURE MAYES
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS.
CALLING SEEING NONE. JUST JUST
REAL SLEEP OVERS ABOUT IT REAL
SIMPLE GOOD GOVERNMENT AND I'M
REALLY APPRECIATIONFOR EVERY.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
ASSEMBLY ASK FOR THE AYE VOTE
AND- CERTAINLY PLEASED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IT IS ELECTION
SEASON CULMINATING IN ON
ELECTION DAY HOLIDAY. OKAY JUST
ONE NOTE IN THIS IS MORE FOR-
OUR ONGOING RESEARCH I
UNDERSTAND THA IN SOME CASES
THESE BALLOT THESE VOTER
INFORMATION GUIDES ARE SENT OUT
THIRD CLASS MAIL. YET
FURTHERING DELAYING THIS
INFORMATION FROM GETTING IN THE
HANDS OF VOTERS UP SO I THINK
ALL OF OUR TIME LINES INTO THE
SERVE A LARGER ISSUE. MOVING TO
VOTE BY MAIL A UNIVERSAL VOTE
BY MAIL KIND OF A UNIVERSE THAT
WERE IN A NUMBER OF THESE TIME
LINES ARE GOING TO HAVE TO BE
ADJUSTED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
NEW REALITY SO THEY'LL BE SOME
ONGOING WORK ON THIS BUT WITH
THAT I ASK. FOR AN ADULT.
CRUCIALLY THAT. MR MULLIN AND
JUST REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSTANT- FOCUS ON GOOD
GOVERNANCE MEASURES AND YOU'RE
QUITE THE UNITER. AND BRING
EVERY ALL ALL THE WITNESSES AND
ALL OF THE MEMBERS TOGETHER
BEHIND THIS BILL. I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT IT- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN HI.
BERMAN I SEE ARE TELL HI SAY
ARCHER I SENATE. PANEL HI LO.
LO HI MAYES. MAYES MULLIN. FIVE
ONE ALL RIGHT BLANCA RUBIO.
BONTA RUBIO. I AND THAT BILL IS
OUT SO. THE FIRST BILL WITH A
FULL VOTE TODAY MISTER MULLIN-
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT AB
ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN. YES THANK%
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ALL TO
GET BY THANK YOU NICKEL BACKER
OF YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF
FORMERLY OF ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
WHEN TO BY THE WAY FOR HER WORK
AND CONTRIBUTIONS ON THIS BILL
AND I ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED DID COMMENT
SIX OF THE ANALYSIS AB ELEVEN
THIRTY SEVEN SEEKS TO EXPAND.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR AUTOMATIC
VOTER REGISTRATION IN
CALIFORNIA SHIFTING VOTER
REGISTRATION FROM AN OPT INTO
AN OPT OUT APPROACH OTHERWISE
REFERRED TO AS AUTOMATIC VOTER
REGISTRATION HOLDS IMMENSE
PROMISE FOR INCREASING VOTER
REGISTRATION RATES. AND
IMPROVING OVERALL CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
CALIFORNIA WAS A SECOND STATE
IN THE US TO ESTABLISH A
MECHANISM FOR AUTOMATIC VOTER
REGISTRATION OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
THE NEW MOTOR VOTERACT IN
WHICH ELIGIBLE INDIVIDUALS
SEEKING SERVICES TO THE DMV ARE
AUTOMATICALLY REGISTERED TO
VOTE. UNLESS THEY OPTED OUT
PROGRAMS FOR AB ARE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THROUGHOUT THE
NATION OF LEAD TO SIGNIFICANT
INCREASES IN VOTER REGISTRATION
RATES ACROSS THE BOARD I THINK
TWENTY SEVEN PERCENT- INCREASES
THE NUMBER THAT I SAW EXPANDING
THE SCOPE OF CALIFORNIA CVR
EFFORTS WILL HELP REACH
ELIGIBLE. INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
EXISTING PROGRAMS TO THE DMV
DOES NOT ALREADY THIS BILL
SIMPLY ASKS THAT THE SECRETARY
OF STATE'S OFFICE CONDUCTED
STUDY. BUT EXISTING PRO AND
EFFORTS. FOR VOTER REGISTRATION
EFFORTS INCLUDING AUTOMATIC
VOTER REGISTRATION AS WELL AS
IDENTIFY OTHER STATE AGENCIES
THAT HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
INCORPORATE AUTOMATIC VOTER
REGISTRATION EFFORTS. INTO
THEIR EXISTING OPERATIONS WHILE
ALSO PROTECTING. NON CITIZENS
FROM MISTAKEN REGISTRATION. IN
DOING THIS AB ELEVEN THIRTY
SEVEN TAKES THE FIRST STEP IN
AUGMENTING. AUGMENTING OUR
AUTOMATIC VOTER REGISTRATION
CALIFORNIA WITH ME ON THE PHONE
MELISSA ROMERO OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS AS WELL AS
MARIAN SCHNEIDER WITH THE
BRENNAN CENTER. FOR JUSTICE.
GOT A MOTION AND A SECOND AND I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO GO FIRST
TO MARIAN SCHNEIDER FROM THE
BRENNAN CENTER FOR JUSTICE.
THANK YOU CARE BERMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
TODAY. I'M AN ADVISER TO THE
BRENNAN CENTER FOR JUSTICE AT
NYU. THE RENDON CENTER THE
NONPARTISAN PUBLIC POLICY IN
MALL INSTITUTE THAT WORKS TO
REFORM REVITALIZED AND DEFEND
OUR COUNTRY SYSTEM OF DEMOCRACY
AND JUSTICE. BRENNAN CENTER
SUPPORT SB ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN
FOR SEVERAL REASONS. FIRST AB
ARE WORKS OF BRANDON BROWNER
STUDY FOUND THAT VOTER
REGISTRATIONS INCREASED BY
TWENTY SIX POINT 8% COMPARED TO
BEFORE AB ARE AT THE CALIFORNIA
DMV. AND ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA DELEGATION PROJECT
AB ARE REDUCE THE CYCLICAL
NATURE OF VOTER REGISTRATION
SHOWING A STEADY INCREASE IN
REGISTRATIONS AFTER THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ELECTION. RATHER THAN
A SIGNIFICANT DROP OFF AS WAS
TYPICAL BEFORE APR. SECOND NOT
EVERY CALIFORNIAN INTERACTS
WITH THE DMV. AS OF THE END OF
TWENTY TWENTY TO BE HAVE BEEN
REPORTED THAT IT CONDUCTED
EIGHT POINT SEVEN MILLION
DRIVER'S LICENSE AND ID
TRANSACTIONS. FOR ALL USERS
CITIZENS AND NONCITIZENS ALIKE
MANY CALIFORNIANS ONLY DEAL
WITH THE B. AND B. ONCE EVERY
FIVE YEARS THAT WOULD BE ALL.
OTHER VOTER REGISTRATION
AGENCIES SEARCH SIMILARLY LARGE
NUMBERS OF CALIFORNIANS. FOR
EXAMPLE THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES SERVED EIGHT
MILLION PEOPLE ANNUALLY. AB ARE
NEEDS TO REACH A MORE DIVERSE
POPULOUS THAT ACCURATELY
REFLECTS THE DIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION. IN
TWENTY TWENTY BARELY SIXTY
THOUSAND VOTERS WERE REGISTERED
IN ALL OF THE OTHER NON D. N.
B. MOTOR REGISTRATION AGENCIES
AND IN TWENTY SIXTEEN A HUNDRED
AND FORTY SIX THOUSAND VOTERS
REGISTERED. AB ELEVEN THIRTY
SEVEN WILL HELP REGISTER MORE
VOTERS OF THOSE AGENCIES. THIRD
AB ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN WISELY
REQUIRES CAREFUL STUDY AROUND
THE SECURITY OF DATA TRANSFER
AND PROTECTING NONCITIZENS FROM
IN A CERTAIN REGISTRATION.
ACCORDING TO THE US CENSUS
BUREAU AND THE MIGRATION POLICY
INSTITUTE CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO
ALMOST ELEVEN MILLION FOREIGN
BORN IMMIGRANTS. 53% ABOUT FIVE
POINT SIX MILLION ARE
NATURALIZED CITIZENS. ACCORDING
TO THE PEW RESEARCH CENTER OF
THE REMAINING. IMMIGRANTS ABOUT
HALF ARE LEGAL RESIDENTS AND A
LITTLE LESS THAN HALF ARE UNDER.
APPROXIMATELY 2212% OF. SPEAK
NOW IN. GIVEN THE THAT THEY IT
IS. THAT THE NAY AND I. TO ASK
OUT OF BIRTH. IS CLEAR. OFFERED
MULTIPLE CLIENTS THAT IS
UNDERSTOOD BY THE AND YOU. AN
ATTEMPT TO EMPHASIZE. THIS
REQUIRES PRIORITIZING LANGUAGE
ACCESS FOR USERS ALSO AGENCIES
MUST INCLUDE AUTOMATIC FILTERS
THAT PREVENT THE TRANSFER VOTER
REGISTRATION. WHICH ABOUT THE
VOTE. FINALLY IN THE NATIONAL
CONTACT WITH NO SECRET THAT
THIS BILL DOES NOT COME IN A
VACUUM BUT RATHER AT A TIME OF
GREAT STRAIN TO OUR DEMOCRACY.
RENDON CENTER IS TRACKING THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE BUILT IN
FORTY SEVEN STATES THAT WOULD
RESTRICT VOTING RIGHTS AND
MARKLEEVILLE BURDENS TO VOTER
REGISTRATION CURTAIL THE
ABILITY OF VOTERS TO VOTE EARLY
OR MAIL IN THEIR BALLOTS. ALL
<c.green>ASED ON THE FALSE ASSERTION</c>
THAT THE TWENTY TWENTY ELECTION
WAS FRAUDULENT. IN THAT SENSE
IT IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO
ADVANCE MEASURES THAT
STRENGTHEN OUR DEMOCRACY AND
ENCOURAGED VOTER PARTICIPATION.
THIS BILL WOULD DO THAT AB
ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN WICKETS
CALIFORNIA AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PUT FORTH A STRONGER MODEL FOR
INCLUSIVE AUTOMATIC VOTER
REGISTRATION THANK YOU ONE THAT
EMBRACES A MORE DIVERSE SET OF
ELIGIBLE VOTERS THE GODDESS OF
WHEN THEY CHOOSE TO INTERACT
WITH THE STATE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISS SNYDER
MOVING ON TO MS ROMERO- MANY OF
THREE MINUTES FOR TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR.
OF THE COMMITTEE. ANALYSTS WERE
NEAR FOR THE AFFAIRS MAN WITH
THE K. WE GET COMFORTABLE
BETTER. I BELIEVE IN SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTY THEY AND ONE
RECOGNIZE I THINK THE PHONE
NUMBER DEDICATED AND WORK
EXPAND TO THE- DESPITE ON THE
MAP HAPPEN AROUND THE-
CALIFORNIA HAS ALWAYS A- LIGHT
THE PATH LAST REFORM. THANK THE
BILL AND PROTECTING DEMOCRACY
AND ONCE AGAIN HAVE AN UPPER TO
A MASS LEADER PASSING POLICY TO
RADICALLY EXPAND ELECTRIC BIKES
IN THE AUTOMATIC VOTER
REGISTRATION MORE AGENCIES.
HISTORIC VOTER TURNOUT NUMBERS
AND NUMBER TWENTY TWENTY
GENERAL ELECTION CAUGHT MANY OF
THE CELEBRITIES ESPECIALLY
THOSE EARLY VOTER TURNOUT
NUMBERS BUT THAT WASN'T THE
FULL STORY. 80% OF REGISTERED
VOTER TURNOUT WENT DIRECTLY
HIGH THE CONTEXT OF THE FACT
THAT THE WORLD ELIGIBLE VOTER
TURNOUT WITH ONLY SIXTY SEVEN
PERCENT. WE HAVE THE ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT PEOPLE OF COLOR AND
YOUNG PEOPLE CONTINUE TO BE
UNDERREPRESENTED IN CALIFORNIA
ELECTRIC COMPARED TO THEIR
SHARE OF THE OVERALL ELIGIBLE
VOTER POPULATION. AND ACCORDING
TO RESEARCH RELEASED THIS YEAR
BY THE PREFERRED BECAUSE OF THE
MODESTY. FARED VOTER
PARTICIPATION ACTUALLY GREW IN
NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY FOR
WORKING OUT AN ASIAN AMERICAN
VOTERS COMPARED TO THE TOTAL
POPULATION. AND IN PART AGE AND
RACE RACIAL DISPARITIES AND
VOTER TURNOUT HAPPY WITH
DISTRACTION RATE FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE PEOPLE OF COLOR. IN
CALIFORNIA. LEGISLATURE HAD PUT
THE TIME AND AGAIN. BUT
POLICIES AIMED AT. TO EXPAND
ELECTRIC PRIORITIZE UNDER A-
GREW CONTINUE TO BE THE COLOR
IN THE TOP RIGHT. I HOPE THE
LEAD. THREE AND THE POTENTIAL
EXISTS EXPANDING ADAM VOTER. TO
THE EXACTLY THE- THANK YOU WE
URGE EITHER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR ROMERO. WE I HAVE NO
WHEN AND I'LL- SO WE WILL- NOW
MOVE TO ADDITIONAL. AND OR NOT
TO A LOVE THIRTY SO AS OUR DUE
TO LIMITS FOR THE HEARING. THE
POP OFF TEN MINUTES AND TOLD
FOR ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COME ALL
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES ARE
LIMITED PROVIDING THEIR NAME
THE ORGANIZATION OF THE
REPRESENT IF ANY AND THE
POSITION ON THE BILL. WILL
START HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
ROOM WHICH IS PROVIDE THEIR
POSITION. SAYING NINE ANYBODY
ON A REMOTE TESTIMONY. SEEING
NONE- THE META MODERATOR LET'S
OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WHO IS A
BROTHER POSITION ON AB ELEVEN
THIRTY SEVEN. AND A REMINDER-
PLEASE JANET DOES YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION REPRESENT IF ANY
AND POSITION ON THE BILL. THANK
YOU AND IT'S ONE ZERO WE'LL GO
TO LINE OF ONE HUNDRED PLEASE
GO AHEAD. IF THE VAL MORGAN
DISTRICT JAN REPRESENTING THE
STATE OF JEFFERSON AND I OPPOSE
AB ONE THIRTY AT ELEVEN THIRTY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT WEEK
NOT A LINE OF. ONE TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT'S JUST A
NATURAL PLASTER COUNTY HIGHEST
HOSE A. B. ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN
THERE SHOULD BE A CONSCIOUS
EFFORT NOT AUTOMATIC. THANK YOU
I'M NOT A MODERATOR JUST JUST
FOR SO WE KNOW ARE THERE A LOT
OF WITNESSES ON THE LINE. I
HAD. ABOUT A DOZEN OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH PLEASE CONTINUE.
YOU'RE WELCOME AND A BLIND ONE
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH I STRONGLY OPPOSE STATE.
NEED TO GET SOME- GINO HILLS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT THANK
LINE FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS CHRIS FOSTER FROM
HUNTINGTON BEACH STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB ONE ONE THREE SEVEN.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT CALLER. SB
ONE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JESSICA CHRISTOPHER INDEPENDENT
VOTER OPPOSED TO THE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MA'AM THAT LINE VOTER
PLEASE. CALLER. ONE SEVEN
EIGHT. ONE SEVENTEEN YEAR OPEN.
CLAUDIA KELLER NEVADA COUNTY
STRONGLY OPPOSE LEVINSON THIRTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER. AB ONE THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
MARLENA BRAIN SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
AND I OPPOSE AB. ELEVEN THIRTY
SEVEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH MA'AM
NEXT CALL. FIND TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AMY CHAU
PLASTER COUNTY STRONGLY OPPOSE
A. B. ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ONE THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NANCY BURROWS ORANGE COUNTY AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB ONE ONE
THREE SEVEN. THANK YOU MA'AM
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. SIXTY TWO.
YES THIS IS MARKET KESSLER
FRESNO CALIFORNIA AND I TOTALLY
OPPOSE A. B. ELEVEN THIRTY
SEVEN THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. EIGHTY ONE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS JACK
WILKINSON MARIN COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. ONE ONE THREE
SEVEN THANK YOU SIR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI RHINELANDER RIVERSIDE COUNTY
IT GROW WE OPPOSE AB ONE
SEVENTY ONE THIRTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU SIR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NUMBER ONE FORTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD SHOULD BE AT THE END. ONE
FORTY ONE TWENTY. THREE ORDER
LACKS LINE WOULD BE ONE FORTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE
MARIN COUNTY EIGHTY EIGHT POINT
ONE THREE SEVEN THANK YOU. AND
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WE ARE NEXT LINE IT'S ONE
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS STEVE CHOKE FROM
PLACERVILLE COUNTY FASTER
COUNTY I MEAN ARE I AM TOTALLY
OPPOSED TO MAYBE ELEVEN THIRTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK THIRTY
TO YOUR LINES OPEN. MY NAME IS
GWEN MYERS FROM PLASTER COUNTY
AND I AM OPPOSED TO A. B.
ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
IN OUR NEXT ONE OF LINE ONE
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. M. A
CART MARIN COUNTY STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB. ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN.
ANY OTHERS SHOULD BE ONE THEN
ZERO. THIRD WAY THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE ONE LITTLE LINE SEVENTY
NINE COULD GO AHEAD. HERE THIS
REPORT FROM ALAMEDA A OPPOSE
LEVIN SEVENTY NINE. THANK YOU.
AND WE GOT A LINE OF THIRTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAROL
WILSON AT BOTH AB ELEVEN THIRTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU. AND MY
FAVORITE LINE ONE OH SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE JAMES
WICKMAN LOS ANGELES COUNTY WHO
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU.
MAN WHAT SEVENTY NINE SEVENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHE
EUROPE AGAIN THE CLIENT.
SEVENTY EIGHT. LET'S MOVE ON. I
KNOW FOR THE NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS AT THIS POINT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BRING IT BACK TO
COLLEAGUES FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND THE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. MR MAYS. YEAH I JUST
WANTED TO I KNOW THAT THERE IS
TO ADD SOME OPPOSITION TO ON
THIS THIS IS A STUDY BILL. AND
I THINK THERE'S PROBABLY SOME
CONCERNS SO MANY TALK ABOUT
AUTOMATIC VOTER REGISTRATION OF
THEIR BE PEOPLE THAT WOULD. NOT
LEGALLY BE ALLOWED TO VOTE THAT
OUGHT THAT WOULD WOULD BE
ALLOWED TO VOTE BUT THIS BILL
ACTUALLY SPECIFICALLY. SAYS IN
THE LANGUAGE NOT JUST IN THE
ALICE'S BEEN THE LANGUAGE OF
THE BILL- THAT- THAT THAT-
WOULD YOU WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
THERE IS- INFRASTRUCTURE IN
PLACE. TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
PEOPLE WHO WOULD NOT BE ALLOWED
TO VOTE- ARE NOT REGISTERED. A
DEVOTE SO I'M IN THE SUPPORT OF
THIS TODAY. THEY MISSED RAISE.
ANY ADDIIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COLLEAGUES SEEING
NONE BRING IT BACK TO THE
AUTHOR FOR A CLOSE. ALL THAT MR
MAYES- COMMENT STAND AS MY
CLOTHES IT IS A STUDY BILL
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO- A DIG
AGAIN ON WHAT WORKED PRIMARILY
BUT WHAT ALSO DIDN'T WORK HOW
DO WE PROTECT NONCITIZENS FROM
MISTAKEN REGISTRATION AND HOW
DO WE TAKE THIS TO THE NEXT
STEP. IN TERMS OF THE SUCCESSES
OF AUTOMATIC VOTER REGISTRATION
CALIFORNIA AND ASTRONOMICAL.
THANK YOU MISTER MULLIN WHILE
THE NEW MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM HAS
HAD ITS CHALLENGES I BELIEVE IT
HAS BEEN WILDLY SUCCESSFUL IN
REGISTERING ELIGIBLE
INDIVIDUALS TO VOTE. SO I THINK
EXPLORING WHETHER OTHER VOTER
REGISTRATION AGENCIES HAVE THE
ABILITY TO EXPAND THEIR SYSTEMS
TO ACCOMMODATE AUTOMATIC VOTER
REGISTRATION IS WORTHWHILE. FOR
THESE REASONS I AM HAPPY TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
BERMAN. I BERMAN I SAY ARE
TELLING. SAY ARE TO KNOW
BENNETT. SENATE I LOW LO I
MAYES MAYES I MULLIN. MULLIN
I'D BLOW RUBIO WELCOME RUBIO I.
SIX TO ONE. THE BILL IS OUT SIX
TO ONE- THANK YOU MUCH. I'M
GONNA TURN THE HEARING OVER
DEVICES HERE TO. ALL RIGHT THE
NEXT ITEM ON THE AGENDA IS AB
THIRTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BERMAN. MISTER CHAIR YOU MAY
PRESENT YOUR BILL THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THIS IS A ARCHER
CALIFORNIA MADE SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES TO THE WAY THAT IT
CONCLUDED THE NOVEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY PRESIDENTIAL GENERAL
ELECTION TO PROTECT BOTH VOTERS
AND POLL WORKERS LAST YEAR I
AUTHORED AB EIGHT SIXTY WHICH
WITH THE SUCCESSFUL BI PARTISAN
EFFORT TO SEND EVERY ACTIVE
REGISTERED VOTER A BALLOT AMONG
OTHER PROVISIONS ACCORDING TO
THE SECRETARY OF STATE EIGHTY
SIX AND A HALF PERCENT OF THE
SEVENTEEN AND A HALF MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WHO PARTICIPATED
IN THE NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
GENERAL ELECTION. VOTED ON THE
BALLOT THAT WAS MAILED TO THEM
DATA SHOWS THAT SENDING
EVERYONE A BALLOT IN THE MAIL
PROVIDES ACT VOTERS ACCESS
NEWMAN VOTERS GET BALLOTS IN
THE MAIL OF THE VOTE AB THIRTY
SEVEN WILL ENSURE EVERY ACTIVE
REGISTERED VOTER BLESS YOU IS
MAILED A BALLOT FOR EVERY
ELECTION THEY ARE ELIGIBLE TO
VOTE IN SIMILAR PROVISIONS IN
MY EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTY LAST YEAR
AB THIRTY SEVEN MAKES A NUMBER
OF OTHER IMPORTANT
ACCOMMODATIONS TO HELP%
FACILITATE THE EXPECTED SURGE
IN VOTING BY MAIL IN FUTURE
ELECTIONS. IT ALLOWS COUNTIES
TO BEGIN PROCESSING A RETURN TO
VOTE BY MAIL BALLOTS EARLIER SO
THAT THEY CAN BETTER MANAGE
THEIR WORKLOADS AND GET MORE
BALLOTS COUNTED ON ELECTION
NIGHT AND EXTENDS THE DEADLINE
FOR RECEIPT OF VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOT SO THAT VOTERS ARE NOT
DISENFRANCHISED BUT POTENTIAL
POSTAL SERVICE DELAYS IT ALLOWS
ALL VOTERS TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE FLEXIBILITY OFFERED BY
REMOTE ACCESSIBLE VOTE BY MAIL
SYSTEMS WHICH CAN BE ESPECIALLY
HELPFUL FOR VOTERS WHO NEED
REPLACEMENT BALLOTS OR WHO WANT
TO RECEIVE A BALLOT IN THE
PREFERRED LANGUAGE. FINALLY SB
THIRTY SEVEN ENSURES THAT ALL
CALIFORNIA VOTERS HAVE THE
ABILITY TO TRACK THEIR BALLOTS
pSYSTEM AND OUR PROCESS BY
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS SB THIRTY
SEVEN IS SUPPORTED BY VARIOUS
CALIFORNIA ORGANIZATIONS
REPRESENTING DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WERE GONNA NOW
MOVES TO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AS A
REMINDER EACH PRIMARY WITNESS
HAS A MAXIMUM OF THREE MINUTES
WE LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE DEAN
LOGAN AND NICOLAS REHANI SO
WE'RE GONNA START WITH A
PRIMARY WITNESS DEAN LOGAN IN
FAVOR. OF THE BILL. SUPPORTED
BILL. AFTER MR VICE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS DEAN LOGAN AND I'M THE
REGISTRAR RECORDER COUNTY CLERK
FOR LOS ANGELES COUNTY. AND I'M
TESTIFYING TODAY ON BEHALF OF
OUR BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF AB THIRTY SEVEN I
WANT TO THANK CHAIR BERMAN FOR
OFFERING THE BILL AND FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP AND SUPPORT AND
ADDRESSING CRITICAL LECTINS
ISSUES. FOR CALIFORNIA. AB
THIRTY SEVEN BUILDS ON THE
SUCCESSFUL MITIGATION PUT IN
PLACE TO ENSURE SAFE SECURE AND
ACCURATE ELECTIONS IN TWENTY
TWENTY. IN THE BASE OF THE
PANDEMIC. DUE IN LARGE PART TO
THE PROACTIVE STANCE TAKEN AND
THE RESOURCES PROVIDED IN
CALIFORNIA TO PREPARE FOR AND
ADMINISTER THE PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION. VOTERS WERE ABLE TO
CAST THEIR BALLOTS SAFELY AND
SECURELY AND RECORD VOTER
PARTICIPATION WITH RECORDED.
IMPORTANTLY EIGHTY THIRTY SEVEN
INSURANCE VOTERS ACROSS THE
STATE ARE PROVIDED WITH
CONSISTENT SERVICES AND ACCESS
FOR ALL LOCAL AND STATE
ELECTIONS GOING FORWARD.
INCLUDED A PROVISION TO ENSURE
VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT- OUR MAIL
TO ALL ACTIVE REGISTERED VOTERS
AND SERVICES THAT ALLOW VOTED
TO TRACK THE STATUS OF THEIR
VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT. WHILE
MAINTAINING THE SAFETY NET OF
IN PERSON AND ACCESSIBLE VOTING
OPTIONS. AB THIRTY SEVEN
PROTECT VOTERS FROM IMPACT OF
EXTENDED TRANSIT TIME WHEN
RETURNING BALLOTS THROUGH THE
MAIL. BY EXTENDING THE TIME FOR
RECEIPT A BALLOT THE BALLOT
POSTMARKED ON OR BEFORE
ELECTION DAY. AND IT EXPANDS
THE ACCESSIBILITY REQUIREMENTS
FOR BALLOT TRACKING TO VOTERS
WITH DISABILITIES AS WELL AS
OUR MILITARY AND OVERSEAS
CITIZENS. AB THIRTY SEVEN ALSO
PRIORITIZES AND FACILITATE THE
TRANSPARENT AND ACCURATE CAMERA
THING PROCESS. BY ENABLING
COUNTY TO SECURELY PROCESS
RETURN BALLOTS UPON RECEIPT
HELPING TO ENSURE TIMELY AND
SUBSTANTIVE ELECTION RESULTS ON
ELECTION NIGHT. FOR THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF OUR COMMUNITIES
AS WELL AS FOR OUR ELECTORAL
PROCESS IT'S BENEFICIAL FOR THE
STATE TO CONTINUE TO PUT IN
PLACE. PROVISIONS THAT ENSURE
OUR ELECTIONS ARE SAFE AND
ACCEPTABLE FOR ALL CALIFORNIA
VOTERS. BASED ON THE
DEMONSTRATED SUCCESS OF THESE
MODELS IN TWENTY TWENTY AND
TWENTY SURE CONSISTENCY OF
SERVICES ACROSS ALL COUNTIES.
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES
RESPECTFULLY. ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OUR NEXT.
THE NICKEL REALITY ARE YOU ON.
YEAH- HELLO YOU MAY PROCEEDS
ARE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
YEAH OKAY GREAT- MY NAME IS
NICHOLA THREE ANI- ON THE STATE
BOARD CHAIR FOR HELPING
STUDENTS A STUDENT RUN
NONPROFIT THAT WORKS TO PROTECT
THE ENVIRONMENT MAKE COLLEGE
MORE AFFORDABLE AND HELP YOUNG
PEOPLE TURN OUT TO VOTE. YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE THE LARGEST BLOCK OF
POTENTIAL VOTERS IN THE COUNTRY
THEIR OWN VALUES AND IDEAS. AND
FOR OUR DEMOCRACY TO WORK YOUNG
PEOPLE NEED TO PARTICIPATE.
MICHAELEEN YOU'D BETTER CURRENT
IS ON THE RISE IN TWENTY TWENTY
YOU'D BETTER TURNOUT IN
CALIFORNIA INCREASED BY
SEVENTEEN PERCENTAGE POINTS
FROM THE TWENTY SIXTEEN
ELECTION ONE OF THE LARGEST
INCREASES OF ANY STATE.
CALIFORNIANS THAT THEY CAN
DEFEND EVERY VOTER OF VOTE BY
MAIL BALLOT WITH LIKELY A MAJOR
CONTRIBUTOR TO THE INCREASE IN
TURNOUT. AT OTHER STATES TO
IMPLEMENT IT UP BY MAIL
PROGRAMS ALSO SAW THE LARGEST
INCREASES AND YOU'D BETTER CRAP.
AND CALPERS KNOW CALIFORNIA
PEOPLE OUT TO THE COLD IN
TWENTY TWENTY HELP TEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS REGISTER TO VOTE. AND
MADE OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
GET OUT THE VOTE CONTACT. HELP
CALIFORNIANS DIDN'T TURN OUT TO
THE POLLS- AND IN PREVIOUS
YEARS I CAN'T FIT THAT HAD SOME
OF THE HIGHEST TURNOUT RATE.
AND IN MY EXPERIENCE YOUNG
PEOPLE CAN AND CANNOT ISSUE THE
VOTING- WHILE MANNING THE ON
CAMPUS POINT LOCATION AT UCLA
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND FOR THE
PRIMARY ELECTION IN TWENTY
TWENTY- I SPOKE TO STUDENTS
WHO. COULDN'T WAIT IN LINE FOR
TWO HOURS TO VOTE AND HAD TO
LEAVE. SENDING EVERY VOTER OF
THAT BY NOW BALLOT IT'S A
REMINDER TO VOTE. AND A
CONVENIENT OPTION FOR PEOPLE
WHO MIGHT NOT A CHECK THE BOX
TO REGISTER TO VOTE BY MAIL.
BUT STILL THE FACT THAT THE
MOSTCONVENIENT OPTION FOR THEM
WHEN ELECTION DAY COMES AROUND.
WE SHOULD GIVE EVERY ELECTION.
SO I ENCOURAGE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TO VOTE YES ON EIGHTY
THIRD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON NOW TO THE
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. IT LOOKS LIKE WE
HAVE ONE COLEEN BRITAIN. ARE
YOU ON COLEEN. YES I AM ARE YOU
MAY PROCEED MISTER CHAIRMAN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ELECTION INTEGRITY
PROJECT CALIFORNIA OPPOSES A.
B. THIRTY SEVEN FOR A MYRIAD OF
REASONS. OF FIRST IS A
STIPULATION THAT READS THIS
SECTION DOES NOT REQUIRE THAT
ELECTION OFFICIALS MAIL A
BALLOT TO A VOTER WITH AN
INACTIVE VOTER REGISTRATION
STATUS. AND QUOTE THIS WEEK
STATEMENT DOES NOT PROHIBIT
BALLOTS FROM BEING MAILED TO
INACTIVE VOTERS AND CREATE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR UP TO FOUR AND
A HALF MILLION INACTIVE
REGISTRANTS TO HAVE BALLOTS
MAILED TO THEIR LAST KNOWN
ADDRESS. IS IDEA REGIS WASTE OF
TAXPAYER MONEY ASSOCIATED WITH
SUCH AN ACT THIS INVITES VOTER
IMPERSONATION ON A GRAND SCALE.
INSPECTION SHOULD BE
STRENGTHENED TO EXPRESSLY
PROHIBITS BALLOTS FROM. BEING
MAILED TO ENACT YOUR VOTERS.
RECENT AMENDMENT TO SB THIRTY
SEVEN EXCEPT OF MY AND UP SEVEN
DAYS AFTER THE ELECTION
DEADLINE. THIS IS CLEARLY A
GIFT TO WOULD BE BAD ACTORS AND
THE THREAT YOUR ALEXION
INTEGRITY. THE I. P. C. AID
MAIN OBJECTION TO AB THIRTY
SEVEN LIES IN THE CONTINUED
DISARRAY OF VOEPEL THE
STATEWIDE VOTER DATABASE. THIS
ISSUE SHOULD BE OF PRIME
IMPORTANCE TO EVERY LEGISLATURE
AND UNTIL IT IS RESOLVED NO
FURTHER LAWS SHOULD BE THAT
RELY ON VOEPEL INTEGRITYSHOULD
BE PASSED. OF CONTRARY TO THE
MATH NO I'M NOT MUCH SURE THAT
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE OF PROBLEMS
HERE'S WHAT ACTUALLY HAPPENS.
IN THE NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
ELECTION. CALIFORNIA MAIL
BALLOTS TO FOUR HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THREE REGISTRANTS
WHO HAD NOT VOTED OR UPDATED
THEIR REGISTRATION. AND TWELVE
PLUS YEARS. FORTY ONE THOUSAND
NINE HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE HAD
MOVED CANCEL INACTIVES.
DECEASED OR FAILED TO RESPOND
TO NOTICE THAT NOTED ON THEIR
RECORDS BUT THEY THEY WERE
SPENT A BALLOT ANYWAY. SIXTY
SIX THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED AND
FIFTY OF THESE QUESTIONABLE
REGISTRANTS VOTED IN THE
NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ELECTION.
YOU FOR YOUR ASSURE PEOPLE THAT
THERE ARE SAFEGUARDS. I WANT
YOU TO NOTE THAT ARE PROMINENT
REGISTER OF VOTERS FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA DECLARED
THAT THIS PROCESS IS SUBJECTIVE.
ELECTORAL RESULTS SHOULD NOT BE
SUBJECTIVE ONE CITIZEN ONE VOTE
AN OBSCURE OBJECTIVE TALLY
SHOULD BE A DETERMINER OF
ELECTIONS. APPROXIMATE OUTCOMES
BASED ON VERY GENEROUS AND
SUBJECTIVE SIGNATURE MATCHING
IS OFFENSIVE TO A DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS. WHEN THERE ARE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
EXPENSE BALLOTS IN THE SYSTEM
THE CHANCES OF UNTOLD NUMBERS
OF THEM BEING ILLEGITIMATELY.
HI IT'S OBJECTIVE AN EXTREMELY
LAX STANDARD OF SIGNATURE
VERIFICATION ALLOWS THOSE TO BE
COUNTED. YES WHAT ELSE HAPPENED
IN TWENTY TWENTY I'M GONNA HAVE
YOU WRAPPED UP YOU'RE JUST
ABOUT AT THE THREE MINUTE.
LIMIT OKAY. OKAY THANK YOU ALEX
WERE MAILED TO THREE THOUSAND.
THREE HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO
INDIVIDUALS ON THE DEATH. ON
THE DEATH OF INDEX. AND SIXTY
EIGHT OF THOSE VOTED YOU ELBOW
ON BUT A DOG CLOSING. UNTIL
VOEPEL CAN BE SHOWN TO BE
CONSIDERABLY MORE LIABLE AND
VOTER ROLL MAINTENANCE RANGE
LEVELS CAN BE SHOWN TO BE A
LEGITIMATE. THE MAILING OF
BALLOTS TO ALL REGISTRANTS IS
RECKLESS IN THE EXTREME WELL
ILLEGITIMACY OF ALL ELECTRIC.
EMAIL ADDRESS UPDATE. THE
CALIFORNIA MUST BE DEMAND MUST
BE DEMAND MORE CALLS FOR
CAUTION. URGES NO VOTE THAT YOU
THANK YOU MA'AM SORRY TO HAVE
INTERRUPT YOU LIKE THAT BUT- WE
HAVE SOME TIME ANSWERING. I AM.
HELLO ARE WE ARE NOW TO MOVE ON
TO A- WAY. IN SUPPORT A- TO AB
TO. AS A REMINDER DUE TO THE
TIME. FOR THE COMMITTEE TODAY
COMMITTEE HEARING- THE PUBLIC
WILL HAVE TEN MINUTES IN TOTAL
TIME FOR ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENT. ALL ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES ARE LIMITED TO
PROVIDING THEIR NAME. THE
ORGANIZATION THAT THEY
REPRESENT IF ANY. AND THEIR
POSITION ON THE BILL THAT'S IT.
ARE WE WILL START HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM IS THERE ANYBODY
IN THE COMMUNITY ROOM THAT
WISHES TO PROVIDE THEIR
POSITION ON TV THIRTY SEVEN.
HAS SEEN NONE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. THAT WOULD
WISH TO PROVIDE THEIR POSITION.
HEARING NONE. ARE WE WILL NOW
OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WHO WISH
TO PROVIDE THEIR POSITION ON AB
THIRTY SEVEN. MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANYBODY ON THE LINE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK EITHER IN
SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION OF AB.
THIRTY SEVEN. WITH THEM IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT ON AB
THIRTY SEVEN IN A PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME- FOR TO GO TO
LINE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS GLORIA MASSEY KEY
NOW VENTURA COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL AB
THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT WEEK- I THINK.
THE NEXT TO GO TO LINE FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS AND SWEDBERG IN SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT WEEK OR. MEXICO
TO NINE THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS WHY MYERS
PLASTER COUNTY. THE OPINIONS
THAT THEY'RE MENTALLY OPPOSED
TO THIRTIES SB THIRTY SEVEN.
THANKS FOR CALLING IN MA'AM
NEXT BEAKER. TO GO TO LINE ONE
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
THIS IS ROBIN ELLIS FROM SAN
DIEGO WOMEN D. I. G. N. I
STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B. THIRTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU MAN
NEXT BIGGER. MEXICO TO LINE
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
JUSTIN MASTERCLASS ARE COUNTY I
TOTALLY AGREE ALL COMMENTS OF
THE I. P. C. A. AND I OPPOSE SB
THIRTY SEVEN. THANK YOU SIR
NEXT SPEAKER. I COULD GO TO
LINE ONE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS JESSICA
CHRISTOPHER INDEPENDENT VOTERS
WE RECEIVED SEVERAL BALLOTS.
JUST YOUR OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT
ME ON AIM I THOUGHT THIS. I'M
SORRY WAS THAT ARE YOU SUPPORT
OR OPPOSE. BUT WE ONLY NEED ONE
DOLLAR PER PERSON THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT WEEK PLEASE. CONNECT
TO THE TO LINE FIFTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JENNIFER JOHNSON PLASTER COUNTY.
SEVEN THANK YOU MA'AM WE DIDN'T
HEAR WHERE THE OPPOSE OR
SUPPORT IT CUT OUT WELL I
OPPOSE AB THIRTY SEVEN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MA'AM NEXT WEEK
PLEASE. WE GOT THE LINES NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
GREG ALAMEDA COUNTY WE OPPOSE
A. B. THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU
SIR NEXT BIGGER PLEASE. MEXICO
TO LINE NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS RINKER
BOCK INTER COUNTY ARMEN STRONG
OPPOSITIONSB THIRTY SEVEN
UNLESS THE PROPER SAFEGUARDS IN
PLACE THANK YOU- THAT'S ALL WE
NEED. YEAH WE JUST NEED YOUR
NAME AND THE SUPPORTER OPPOSE
AYE WE APPRECIATE THAT THE NEXT
BIGGER PLAYS. I FORGOT TO LINE
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT A LINE IS
OPEN. ANYBODY THERE LET'S GO
AHEAD MOVE ON TO THE NEXT WEEK
OR. I COULD GO TO LINE ONE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SEVEN
ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF SILICON
VALLEY COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
BIGGER PLEASE. THE NEXT TO GO
TO LINE ONE FORTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BUT YOU CARE MEMBERS
PAT MORAN WITH ERIN READ THE
SOVIETS REPRESENTING THE ORANGE
COUNTY EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. CONNECT
TO THE TIMELINE ONE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DONNA FIVE
MARIN COUNTY TO MAINTAIN THE
INTEGRITY OF MY AYE OPPOSED.
EIGHT EIGHT THIRTY SEVEN
STRONGLY. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NOT TO GO TO
LINE SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MATHIS OFFICER CRTER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF NONPROFIT IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IF THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS OF BENEFITS TAKEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MA'AM
NEXT WEEK REPLACE. MEXICO TO
LINE THE ONE EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JEFF TOM BUT PRESENT IN
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF BLIND
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIR NEXT
BIGGER PLEASE. THE NEXT TO GO
TO LINE ONE FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES I STRONGLY OPPOSE A.
B. THIRTY SEVEN AND I REPRESENT
WOMEN CALLING OUT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AGAIN NEXT BIGGER
CASE. LIKE TO GO TO MIND SEVEN
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. OTHERS
JUST CHAU FROM CAL. I'M TOTALLY
TO SB THIRTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
SIR AND I JUST WANNA LET
EVERYBODY KNOW WE'RE FIVE
MINUTES THROUGH THE FIRST TEN
MINUTE PERIOD SO WE GOT FIVE
MORE MINUTES OF PUBLIC
TESTIMONY AND THEN WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO MOVE ON. NEXT BIGGER
PLATES. I COULD GO TO LINE ONE
FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JERRY CRAIG SEVERINO COUNTY
THROW IT THOUGH THE V. THIRTY
HELLO THANK YOU SIR NEXT CALLER.
LIKE TO GO TO LINE ONE THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I NEED TO
TRAIN CRUZ COUNTY. OPPOSE THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE SB
THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU MA'AM
NEXT IN LINE ONE FORTY TWO. ONE
FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS VICTORIA BALLING IN
ORANGE COUNTY AND AS A WHOLE
OBSERVER FROM THE TWENTY TWENTY
ELECTION I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB
THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THE NEXT TO THE TO LINE TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
A NEAT CHAU PLATTER COUNTY
PREVIOUS POLL WATCHER I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB THIRTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
WHO. THE NEXT TO GO TO LINE ONE
OH SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS
IS JAMESWICK FROM LOS ANGELES
COUNTY I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
THIRTY SEVEN. THANK YOU SIR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANKS TO
THE NINE ONE NINETY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH RACHEL
OFTEN FROM SAN MATTEO COUNTY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE IF YOU
WANT US THIRTY SEVEN TO GIVE ME
A B. THIRTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MA'AM NEXT WEEK
PLEASE. LIKE TO GO TO LINE ONE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. IDEA
TAYLOR NEVADA COUNTY STRONGLY
OPPOSED BECAUSE THE ELECTION
INTEGRITY IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THE TO LINE
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. AT RISK
BECAUSE WE NEVER GOT TO
ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU MA'AM
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THE NEXT TO
GO TO LINE ONE EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. STOP THEIR
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU SIR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. CONNECTED TO
LINE SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ASSEMBLY TESTER FROM SAN DIEGO
COUNTY I STRONGLY OPPOSE BILL
AB THIRTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE.
CONNECT TO THE LINE NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ESTRADA FROM
VENTURA COUNTY AYE OPPOSED AB
THREE SEVEN THANK YOU SIR NEXT
CALLER. NEXT WE GO TO LINE THE
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE ASSEMBLY SHANTI HALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
SPEAKER. NEXT DEADLINE ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES MY NAME IS JULIAN MORALES
VENTURA COUNTY WITH THE
ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT I
OPPOSE- AB THIRTY SEVEN THANK
YOU SIR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANKS TO THE TIMELINE ONE
NINETY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
DURAN REYES PRESIDENT OF THE
WOMEN'S VOLUNTEERS IN POLITICS
OPPOSE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANKS TO THE TIMELINE ONE
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS RON LANDER FROM
RIVERSIDE COUNTY I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB ONE THE V. THIRTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU SIR NEXT WEEK
REPLACE. THANKS TO THE TIMELINE
ONE EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NORTH AMERICA WITH A
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS ACCORDING
TO THE CHEN APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH HIM. THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT WEEK REPLACE. MEXICO
TO NINE ONE NINETY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS GEORGE LEAD
FROM CHINESE AMERICANS FOR
LIBERTY IN ORANGE COUNTY. I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB THIRTY
SEVEN IT OPENED THE FLOODGATES
FOR LOCAL BATTLE THANK YOU SIR
NEXT WEEK REPLACE. THE NEXT TO
GO TO LINE ONE OH FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MR SURE THIS DEMOCRAT
IN STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
SIR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. TWO TWO
NINE ONE EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ELAINE BOYNTON L. A. COUNTY
STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B. THIRTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU MA'AM
MODERATOR HOW MANY MORE CALLS
DID WE HAVE ON THERE. HE HAS-
RIGHT ABOUT ARE DEADLINE HERE.
WE HAVE AROUND EIGHTEEN MORE M.
YOU KNOW WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
CLOSE OUR PUBLIC TESTIMONY AT
THAT WE'VE GONE MORE THAN TEN
MINUTES AND WE NEED TO MOVE ON
SO IN THE INTEREST OF BEING
ABLE TO HEAR SOME OF THE OTHER
BILLS ALSO. THANK YOU ALL OF
THOSE PEOPLE THAT CALLED IN TO
EXPRESS THEIR RAG AND THEIR-
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL- ARE THERE ANY WE'RE GONNA
BRING BACK THE COMMITTE AT
THIS TIME ARE THERE ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MENDER. MEMBERS GO
AHEAD MR MACE. THANKS FOR
BRINGING US SOME OF THE SUPPORT
THIS BILL- TODAY- THE QUESTION
THAT I HAVE FOR YOU AND THIS IS
ACTUALLY BRINGS UP- A QUESTION
THAT I HAD THAT- I HAD CALLED
YOU ABOUT- JUST BEFORE THE
ELECTION A IN READ IN REGARDS
TO- THE LANGUAGE THAT IS HERE-
WHAT IF A BALLOT IS POSTMARKED
ON OR BEFORE ALEXION DAY- OR A-
THE- POOREST. TIMESTAMP OR DATE
STAND BY BONAFIDE PRIVATE MAIL
DELIVERY COMPANY. I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT WHAT IS A BONA FIDE
PRIVATE MAIL COMPANY- I ALSO
WANT TO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THAT IDEA OF IF THEY DO. THE-
IF A BALLOT IS NOT POSTMARKED
IN THERE'S NO DATE STAMP ON
THEIR THE PROVISIONS THAT ARE
THERE TO MAKE SURE THAT- WITH
THAT OUT THOUGH. BALLOT WAS
CAST IN THAT IT WAS TIMELY WHAT
SORT OF. OF MEASURES- CAN WE
CAN WE PLACE IN HERE WE SURE
THAT PEOPLE AREN'T CASTING
BALLOTS AFTER THE ELECTION
ESPECIALLY- IN IN AREAS WHERE
THERE MIGHT BE CLOSE A CLOSE
RACE. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION MR MAYES IT'S UP TALK
ABOUT THAT- PAGE FIVE- IT'S THE
STUFF AROUND LINE TWENTY SIX
YEAH THE END I APPRECIATE THAT
I'VE GOT TO ANSWER FOR IT.
WE'RE JUST TALKING ABOUT GIVING
OFFICE HAD THEM BEFORE YEAH I
KNOW I WAS EVEN TOLD ME THAT
ACTUALLY BY THE WAY DID TRY TO
GIVE YOU A QUICK HEADS UP- BUT
AND THEN AGAIN. IF YOU CAN
ANSWER JUST A BONA FIDE WE
COULD TALK ABOUT THIS
AFTERWARDS- AS WELL I DON'T
WANT TO GIVE YET- I DON'T WANNA
TO JAM YOU HERE- THE OHIO SO-
SO IT'S SO I. THREE THEY DON'T
HAVE MY FEAR. THE DEFINITION OF
BONA FIDE- MAIL DELIVERY
SERVICE I CAN GET A FOLLOW UP
WITH YOU ON. ON THAT. IN
REGARDS TO THE CONCERNED ABOUT
YOU KNOW POSTMARKED AND
DIFFERENT. MARKERS THAT THAT-
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS MIGHT LOOK
AT. THE ACCOMMODATION ONLY
APPLIES TO BALLOTS THAT ARE
MAILED. DIFFERS ALL AND IT HAS
BEEN MAILED BY ELECTION DAY.
YEAH AND IN DETERMINING WHETHER
A BALLOT WAS MAILED BY ELECTION
DAY. THE ELECTIONS OFFICIAL
WILL BE ABLE TO LOOK AT THE
POSTMARK ON THE BALLOT OR TURN
ENVELOPE. AND OTHER TRACKING
INFORMATION PROVIDED BY THE US
POSTAL SERVICE OR TO YOUR
POINT. A BONAFIDE PRIVATE MAIL
DELIVERY COMPANY. FOR THE
EXTRAORDINARILY RARE SITUATION
WHERE AN ENVELOPE THAT IS
RETURNED BY MAIL DOES NOT
RECEIVE ANY LEGIBLE POSTMARK.
AND THERE'S NO OTHER TRACKING
INFORMATION. AN ELECTIONS
OFFICIAL BE ABLE TO LOOK AT THE
DATE ON WHICH THE BALLOT WAS
SIGNED AND DATED BY THE VOTER
TOUCHES. YOUR THOUGHT YEAH SO.
IT'S PRETTY TIGHT THIS IS THE
SAME LANGUAGE WE HAD HAVE LOST
ON DIDN'T HEAR ABOUT ANY. OF
THE YOU KNOW ISSUES WITH IT BUT
LET ME GET BACK TO YOU ON YEAH
AND I'LL BE HAPPY TO. WORK WITH
YOU AS YOU AS IS BETTER THIS IS
THE- FIRST HEARING WHAT AND
WE'LL GET TO THAT I KNOW WE HAD
THAT ONE QUESTION. BACK DURING
THE ELECTION A MEMBER CALLED
YOU. YOU'RE ABOUT TO RELATED TO
THIS TO THE SAME THING I AM
GOING TO SUPPORT THIS TODAY-
I'M A STRONG BELIEVER IN HAVE
BEEN FOR YEARS- THAT- FACT I
WANT TO. US TO HAVE A ALL MAIL
BALLOT. ELECTION I THINK IT
MAKES. THE MOST SENSE- AS
PEOPLE BEGIN TO TRANSITION FROM
GOING TO THE POLLS AND THEN
ONCE THEY GET THEIR MAIL
BALLOTS THEY LOVE. HAVING THAT.
THAT MAIL BALLOT I'VE- BEEN
BEEN CASTING. BALLOTS VIA MAIL
FOR THE LAST I THINK TWENTY
YEARS I CAN'T REMEMBER THE LAST
TIME I WAS JUST A- COUPLE VOTER
SO- I DO- BELIEVE. THAT THIS IS
pGO IN IT IS SAFE IT IS SECURE-
AND YOU'RE ABLE TO TRACK.
THINGS IT'S- SO- I'M GONNA BE
SUPPORTING IT TODAY. BRIGITTE
THAT ANY DIFFERENT I DO
REMEMBER HAVING THAT
CONVERSATION- I JUST DON'T
RECALL EXACTLY WHAT YEAH WE'LL
GET IT LOOKING. BACK ON THAT.
RIGHT OTHERS. ELSE HAVE
QUESTIONS. BERMAN MISTER
BENNETT I APPRECIATE BEING A CO
AUTHOR OF THIS THE THEIR
REQUEST AND- I THE AUTHOR OF
FOR OF MOVING- IMPORTANT TO
ALLOW AND THAT THAT THAT THE
WHOLE CONCEPT OF MAIL IN BALLOT
IS A WAY FOR US TO GO I ALSO DO
APPRECIATE THAT THERE WERE
SOME- SOME ISSUES RAISED AT
THAT WE WANT TONIGHT AND I
CERTAINLY KNOW THAT THE OFFICE
IS GOING TO TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY
IN TERMS OF TRYING TO MAKE
SURE. HIS INTEGRITY IS
EVERYTHING AND IF WE WANT TO
HAVE THE ADVANTAGES OF A MAIL
IN BALLOT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT- WE TIGHTEN UP ANY
POSSIBILITIES WERE- SOMEBODY
COULD SAY HEY THERE'S BEEN A-
PRIVATE FIRM HAS BEEN CREATED
JUST TO POST DATE THESE THINGS
HAVE TO ACCEPT HER I'M
CONFIDENT THAT THAT WILL HAPPEN
IS THIS BILL CONTINUES TO MOVE
FORWARD- AND- BUT THE OVERALL
BENEFITS OF THIS ARE ENORMOUS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT- MISTER BENNETT AND I BY
ALL MEANS THAT YOU KNOW I
BELIEVE THAT OUR ELECTION
SYSTEM HERE IN CALIFORNIA IS
REMARKABLY SECURE WORK- IF
ANYBODY HAS EVIDENCE OR PROOF
OF ANY ELECTION TAMPERING AT
ALL. PLEASE LET THE SECRETARY%
OF STATE'S OFFICE NO YOU REACH
OUT TO MY OFFICE AND LET US
KNOW YOU CAN LET LAW
ENFORCEMENT KNOW WE WANT TO
PROSECUTE ANYBODY WHO IS WHO IS
TAMPERING WITH OUR ELECTIONS-
IT BUT THE EVIDENCE OF THAT
THAT HASN'T BEEN BROUGHT TO
ANYBODY'S ATTENTION YET- AND SO
I THINK THAT OUR SYSTEM OF LIKE
THE VOTING IN CALIFORNIA IS
REMARKABLY SECURE. AND VOTERS
SHOULD FEEL CONFIDENT THAT THAT
THEIR VOTE IS BEING COUNTED AND
THAT ONLY PEOPLE WHO CAN VOTE
ARE VOTING PROJECT IF I CAN BE
AS A CO AUTHOR AS WELL ON THE
SERVER THANK YOU MISTER MISS
PROHIBIT HI N. BEFORE YOU'RE
GONNA CLOSE I'LL JUST MAKE A
COUPLE COMMENTS- IT GAVE ME A
WHOLE VOTER ELECTION AND. I
MEAN. THERE'S REALLY. THERE IS
THIS. WITH AND THE STRUGGLE IS
THE- WE DO ONE. WHO SERVICE IS
ENTITLED TO VOTE TO VOTE. WE DO
WANT TO LIMIT VOTER SUPPRESSION
BUT ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THAT
THERE'S A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE IN HERE WHETHER WHAT
HOWEVER THEY GOT YOU KNOW THE
AYE THE- THEIR CONCERNS WERE
RICH A RAISED. THEY HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE INTEGRITY
PART AND JUSTICE MR BENNETT WAS
SAYING- THAT PART HAS TO BE
ADDRESSED IN OUR EFFORTS TO
REFORM THE ELECTION PROCESS-
THE BALLOT IN. THE MAIL IN
BALLOT WAS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WAS EXPRESSED IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE I BELIEVE IT WAS
THERE IS A PANEL ON- D.
ELECTION AL REFORM. AND THE ONE
THING THAT THEY SAID WE SHOULD
THEY SHOULD WOULD BE MOST COST
IS ABOUT IS AN ALL MAIL BALLOT
AND THAT'S WHY. N. A. N. A. N.
A. PAINS ME WHEN PEOPLE JUST
DISMISS THE CONCERNS OF MANY
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO BE SHOULD BE
SURE THAT WHEN THEY GO TO THE
POLLS THEIR VOTE ATUALLY DOES
COUNT. AND IT BECAUSE IF THEY
LOSE THAT CONFIDENCE IN THE
VOTING SYSTEM THAT'S ALSO VOTER
SUPPRESSION BECAUSE IF THEY
LOSE IT AND JUST STOPPED GOING-
THEN WE'RE LOSING THE VOICE OF
THAT PERSON. SO YOU KNOW I CAN
TAKE I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THE DIALOGUE ON HOW
WE ENSURE THAT WE HAVE-
CONFIDENCE IN THE VOTING
SYSTEM- BUYS MANY PEOPLE AS WE
CAN. AND SO WITH THAT I'LL LET
YOU CLOSE AND THEN WE'LL MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT BILL THANKS
APPRECIATE THAT IN A YOU KNOW I
AGREE THAT THAT THERE ARE THERE
IS A- NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO.
HAVE LOST CONFIDENCE IN THE
VOTING SYSTEM YOU KIND OF
DISMISSED THE WHY YOU SAID
WHATEVER THE REASON AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE DIRECTLY
ADDRESS THE WHY AND THE WHY IS
THAT THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND ELECTED
OFFICIALS HAVE LIED TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE. ABOUT THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR ELECTION
SYSTEM AND IT'S A DARN SHAME
THAT THEY DID THAT AND THAT
THEY ARE CREATING UNCERTAINTY
IN IN THE IN THE HEARTS AND
MINDS OF MILLIONS OF AMERICANS.
ABOUT A REMARKABLY SAFE
ELECTION. SYSTEM AND IT WOULD
BE A TRAVESTY. OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
A WE LET THOSE. AND THE
UNCERTAIN THAT'S BEEN CREATED
BY THOSE LAWS IS. TO CAUSE US
TO PUT. THE LAWS IN PLACE THAT
RESTRICT. PEOPLE FROM BEING
ABLE TO VOTE OR MAKE IT HARDER.
FOR PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO VOTE
SO I AGREE WITH YOU COMPLETELY
THAT WE NEED TO DO MORE. TO
EXPRESS TO PEOPLE AND EXPLAIN
TO PEOPLE. THAT ARE ELECTION
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA. IS
REMARKABLY SECURE. BUT I WILL
NOT BE A PART. OF LETTING LIES
TOLD BY THE FORMER PRESIDENT
THE UNITED STATES AND OTHER
ELECTED OFFICIALS. LEAD TO LAWS
THAT SUPPRESS VOTERS IN
CALIFORNIA. I WOULD THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN HI BERMAN
I SAY OUR TELL NO SE ARCH- NO
FAN AT. PLANET I LOW LO I MAYES.
ARAMBULA MULLIN I RUBIO WELCOME
I. SIXTY ONE THAT MOTION GOES
FORWARD SIX ONE SO THAT MOVES
US TO THE NEXT ITEM ON THE
AGENDA ALSO VIA ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN THIS WILL BE A B. TWO
THIRTY SIX THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US AGAIN AND- GO AHEAD
WITH YOUR BILL. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES IN
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS THE FAIR
POLITICAL PRACTICES COMMISSION.
HAS IDENTIFIED A TROUBLING
PATTERN WHICH LIMITED LIABILITY
COMPANIES HAVE MADE LARGE
CONTRIBUTIONS AND EXPENDITURES
WITHOUT MEANINGFUL DISCLOSURE.
ABOUT THE IDENTITY OF THE
INDIVIDUALS INVOLVED IN THOSE
ALL SEIZE AND ONE PARTICULARLY
EGREGIOUS EXAMPLE AN LLC FORMED
LESS THAN A MONTH BEFORE THE
NOVEMBER TWENTY EIGHTEEN
GENERAL ELECTION. CONTRIBUTED
THREE HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO AN INDEPENDENT
EXPENDITURE COMMITTEE SET UP TO
SUPPORT AND OPPOSE CANDIDATES
FOR MAYOR AND CITY COUNCIL IN
SANTA ANA. AT THAT ELECTION
THAT ALFIE DID NOT DISCLOSE ANY
INFORMATION ABOUT THE
INDIVIDUALS INVOLVED IN HIS
POLITICAL ACTIVITIES. NOR DID
IT DISCLOSE ANY INFORMATION
ABOUT THE SOURCE OF THE FUNDS
THAT THEY USED TO MAKE ITS
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS. AS A
RESULT SANTA ANA VOTERS HAD NO
MEANINGFUL INFORMATION ABOUT
THE TRUE IDENTITY OF THE
PRIMARY FUNDING SOURCE. OF
MAJOR EXPENDITURES IN CITY
ELECTIONS UNFORTUNATELY
EXISTING LAW DOES NOT ENSURE
THAT THERE IS FULL AND TRUTHFUL
DISCLOSURE ABOUT THE SOURCE. OF
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS AND
EXPENDITURES THAT ARE FUNDED BY
LLCS. AB TWO THIRTY SIX
REQUIRES ALL FEES THAT MAKE
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS AND
EXPENDITURES TO PUBLICLY
DISCLOSE SPECIFIED MEMBERS OF
THE L. C. FOR THAT VOTERS HAVE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE TRUE
SOURCE OF FUNDS USED BY ALL
SEIZE. IN STATE ELECTIONS I
WANT TO BRIEFLY ADDRESS THE
OPPOSITION. TO THIS BILL IN ITS
OPPOSITION LETTER THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
SAYS THAT THE BILL IS
UNNECESSARY IN LIGHT OF
REGULATIONS ADOPTED BY THE AT
BBC. AND THAT IS APPLIED.
UNEVENLY BECAUSE IT APPLIES TO
ALL SEES BUT NOT TO UNIONS OR
CORPORATIONS. WELL THE F. PPC'S
REGULATIONS ARE AN IMPORTANT
STEP TO IMPROVING TRANSPARENCY
AROUND POLITICALLY ACTIVE L.
SEES. THE REGULATIONS DO NOT
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC HAS
INFORMATION ABOUT THE SOURCE OF
THE FUNDS. THAT LLCS USED FOR
THE POLITICAL ACTIVITY. WHICH
IS THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL.
FURTHERMORE THIS BILL FOCUSES
L. C. THE BECAUSE IT IS
TARGETED. TO ADDRESS A GAP IN
DISCLOSURE RULES IDENTIFIED BY
THE F. B. P. C. THE F. B. B. C.
HAS NOT SEEN EVIDENCE THAT
OTHER TYPES OF ENTITIES ARE
BEING USED. TO OBSCURE THE
SOURCE OF FUNDS. USING
CALIFORNIA ELECTIONS IN THE
SAME MANNER. WE'VE BEEN IN
CONVERSATION WITH THE CHAMBER
ABOUT THOSE POINTS WHICH WERE
INITIALLY IN WHICH WE WERE
INITIALLY MADE AWARE OF. VIA
THEIR FORMAL LEVEL LETTER OF
OPPOSITION. AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE WITH THEM ON
THIS BILL. AB TWO THIRTY SIX IS
SPONSORED BY THE F. B. B. C.
AND HAS THE SUPPORT OF THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA. ISLANDS IN A CONDO
AT THE LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL FOR
THE F. T. P. C. IS ON THE PHONE
TO TESTIFIED SUPPORT. AND
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION I RESPECTFULLY.
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THE PRIMARY
WITH. THIS PART OF THE BILL ON
THANK YOU HAVE THAT ONE. COULD
BE A PART. YOUR ONLINE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIR AND MY NAME IS
MCCAW AND I AM LIKE COUNCIL FOR
THE FAIR PLAY A PRACTICE
COMMISSION. FIFTY THREE IF THE
STATE COMMISSION THAT
ADMINISTERS AND ENFORCES THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT WHICH
REGULATES CAMPAIGN FINANCING
CONFLICT OF INTEREST LOBBYING
AND GOVERNMENTAL ETHICS.
COMMISSION IS PLEASED TO
SPONSOR THIS VERY IMPORTANT
BATTLE. OVER THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS THE FTC HAS FOUND
INCREASING INSTANCES OF LLCS
BEING USED THE VEHICLES FOR
DARK MONEY IN STATE AND LOCAL
ELECTIONS. UNDER EXISTING LAW
LLC CAN BE FOUND QUICKLY AND
RELATIVELY ANONYMOUSLY AND CAN
MAKE POLITICAL CONTRIBUTIONS
SOON AFTER AND THERE'S USUALLY
NO WAY FOR THE PUBLIC TO FIND
OUT. WHO IS ACTUALLY FUNDING
THE CONTRIBUTION. THE GOAL OF
EIGHTY THREE THREE SIX TO
ADDRESS THE LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY BY SHEDDING LIGHT
ON THE TRUE SOURCE OF FUNDS. BY
ANY L. L. B. OFFENSE MONEY ON
POLITICAL ACTIVITY IN THE STATE
ARE REQUIRING DISCLOSURE OF
CERTAIN MEMBERS OF THE L. L. C.
OR IN OTHER WORDS THE CLOSURE
OF WHO HAS FUNDED THE ALFIE.
THE TYPICALLY EIGHTY TO TWENTY
SIX REQUIRING LLC THAT REACHES
A THRESHOLD LEVEL OF POLITICAL
ACTIVITY THAT WOULD ALREADY
UNDER CURRENT LAW. SUBJECT THE
LLC TO REGULATION UNDER THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT AT THE
COMMITTEE A COMMITTEE SPONSOR
FILE A STATEMENT OF MEMBERS
SECRETARY OF STATE. THE
STATEMENT WOULD NOT DISCLOSE
EVERY MEMBER OF THE L. L. C.
BUT RATHER ONLY THOSE WHO HAVE
A 10% OR GREATER MEMBERSHIP
INTERESTS. OR HAD MADE A
CUMULATIVE CAPITAL CONTRIBUTION
TO THE L. L. C. AB ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS. OR MORE WITHIN A
SPECIFIED PERIOD. APART FROM
THE STATEMENT OF MEMBERS EIGHTY
TWO THREE SIX OFF THE CAR BY
TWO RECENT REGULATE. INCREASING
AVAILABLE ABOUT OUT OF. EVANS
MONEY ON ACTIVITY THE STATE.
WHAT THE THAT THESE ARE CURRENT.
AND THIS OF THE BILL. THAT EXIT
LAW. BEACH REGULATIONS ARE
IMPORTANT STEPS TO INCREASING
TREND. ALONE DON'T GIVE PUBLIC
IN. ABOUT THE TWO SOURCE OF FUN
WHICH IS WHY THIS BILL IS
CRUCIAL. ONE OF THE ORIGINAL
PURPOSE OF THE FOCAL REFORM ACT
WITH TO ESTABLISH STRONG
DISCLOSURE LAWS. THAT THE
PUBLIC IS INFORMED ABOUT THE
PEOPLE AND INTERESTS WHO ARE
FUNDING CAMPAIGNS IN THE STATE.
OF THE SHOULD NOT BE A VEHICLE
FOR CONCEALING IDENTITY FOR
SKIRTING CONTRIBUTION LIMITS.
REQUIRING DISCLOSURE OF AN LLC
FUNDERS WHEN IT SPENDS MONEY
FOR POLITICAL PURPOSES. EIGHTY
TWO THREE SIX STRENGTHENS THE
STATE CAMPAIGN DISCLOSURE LAWS
AND ENSURES THAT THE PUBLIC HAS
THE INFORMATION THEY NEED TO
MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS. THANK
YOU TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS TO CALIFORNIA FOR
THEIR SUPPORT AND THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN. FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
IMPORTANT SUBJECT. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SAY I DO NOT HAVE ANY
OTHER. WOULD IN SUPPORT GO TO
THE PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION SHOP MUHAMMAD GO
AHEAD IF YOU'RE ON THE LINE.
AND THEN- TAKE YOUR SELECTED
CHAIR VICE CHAIR MEMBERS MANAGE
WHAT MUHAMMAD CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND WE GET
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB TWO
THIRTY SIX. EIGHTY TWO THIRTY
SIX EXPENSE THE DISCLOSURE
OBLIGATIONS FOR ALLOCATING
GAUGING POLITICAL ACTIVITIES BY
REQUIRING THEM TO IDENTIFY AND
DISCLOSE THE INDIVIDUAL MEMBERS
OF THE L. G. EVEN IF THOSE
NUMBERS ARE NOT INVOLVED. IN
THE YELLOW SUIT POLITICAL
ACTIVITIES. THIS REQUIREMENT-
AS MENTIONED WILL NOT APPLY TO
ANY OTHER ENTITY JEFF. AND IF
YOU JUST D. ADDITIONALLY
CURRENT REGULATIONS ARE
REQUIRED. TO IDENTIFY NEW
PEOPLE INDIVIDUAL RESPONSIBLE
OFFICER TO DIRECT THE L. D.
CORTICAL ACTIVITY BUT IF THE
GOAL IS TO IDENTIFY AN
INDIVIDUAL ACCOUNTABLE FOR
ANALYSES PUT OUT POLITICAL
ACTIVITY. THE CURRENT READ
GRADUATION TOO SURPRISED. UNDER
THE PROPOSED AB TWO THIRTY SIX
HOWEVER THE STATURE CONTENT TO
HOLD INDIVIDUALS RESPONSIBLE
FOR SEPARATE ENTITIES POLITICAL
SPEECH REGARDLESS OF WHETHER OR
NOT THAT INDIVIDUAL MEMBER OF
THE ELEGY PLAYS A ROLE IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTICIPATION. IN SO
DOING AB TWO THIRTY SIX ALSO
FAILED TO DISTINGUISH BETWEEN A
GENERAL PURPOSE PHD ONE ON
ONETIME LLC IS USED FOR THIS
PURPOSE AND WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS DISTINCTION IS IMPORTANT
WHEN ADDRESSING THE CONCERNS
THE SPELLING SHORTCUTS.
ADDITIONALLY THE HUNDRED
DOLLAR. THRESHOLD IT IS TOO LOW
TO TRIGGER APPLICATION UNDER
THE SPELL WE DO NOT THINK THE
BILL INTENDS TO PLACE
LIMITATIONS ON THE ABILITY OF
FOLKS TO. MAKE DONATIONS OF A
HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR THE
POSTPONEMENT REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS ON INDIVIDUALS WHO
MAKE CONTRIBUTIONS OF A HUNDRED
DOLLARS. WE DO NOT BELIEVE THAT
THE CONCERNS WITH THE INTENT TO
ADDRESS ON NECESSARILY RESOLVED
BY REGULATING INDIVIDUALS WHO
MAKE CONTRIBUTIONS OF SUCH A
SMALL SIZE. FOR THESE REASONS
WE GET RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE FIVE
EIGHTY TWO THIRTY SIX BUT OF
COURSE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
ENGAGING- WITH WITH YOUR OFFICE
FURTHER ON THIS BILL AND ONE
THANK YOU. AND YOUR STAFF IN
PARTICULAR FOR GIVING US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HEARD AND
WORKING WITH US ON THESE ISSUES
THANK YOU THAT. ARE GOOD THANK
YOU WE'RE NOT GOING TO MOVE ON
TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION K. A. B.
TWO THIRTY SIX. THE PUBLIC WILL
HAVE TEN MINUTES IN TOTAL TIME
FOR ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT
BECAUSE. WE HAVE SOME TIME
CONSTRAINTS OF THE- AFTER- ALL
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES ARE
LIMITED TO PROVIDE THEIR NAY.
THEIR ORGAN. THE THEY READ. IF
ANY. END UP AS ON THE- WORLD.
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE IS THERE
A READING THE CA ROOM WHICH IS
TO SPEAK ON. TWO SIX. OF THEIR
DOESN'T TO BE ANYTHING. SO
WE'LL GO TO WITNESS AT THE ROOM
TESTING STATE ARE THERE ANY
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION PEOPLE.
DOES NOT SOUND LIKE WE HAVE
THAT SO WE'LL NOW OPEN THE
PHONE LINE FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES. WHO WISH TO PROVIDE
THEIR POSITION A TWO THIRTY
SIX MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY ON THE LINE WHO WISHES
TO SPEAK EITHER IN SUPPORT OR
IN OPPOSITION. OF AB TWO THIRTY
SIX AND REMEMBER FOLKS. NAME
ORGANIZATION AND OPPOSE OR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WE DO HAVE SEVERAL HERE WE'RE
GOING TO LINE NUMBER FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE
EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN. IS ANYBODY
THERE OF NERVE NOBODY ANSWERS
THIS MOVE ON TO THE NEXT NO NO
RESPONSE I CAN MOVE ON HERE.
WE'LL GO TO LINE. EIGHTY EIGHT
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. EIGHTY
PLEASE. LET'S GO TO THE NEXT.
ALL RIGHT AND WE'VE GOT
DEADLINES SEVENTY EIGHT. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. FIRST ONLINE THERE
ANYWAY AND THEY'RE HAVING THE
EIGHT. DO YOU HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH OUR PHONE LINE. RIGHT
LET'S KEEP GOING. OKAY I
APOLOGIZE HERE I CAN HEAR. THAT
WHEN HEARING NINE NINE FORTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR ROLE
WILL BE VOTERS TO CALIFORNIA
AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU AND WE CAN GO TO LINE
UP OF ONE SUPPORT TEAM ONE
MOMENT IN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
DON'T CARE AT THIS POINT I'M
ONE OF THOSE WHO NOW DON'T GIVE
A **** YOU GUYS HAVE A GOOD
DAY. NEXT WEEK PLEASE. AND THAT
NO NO FURTHER ONES AT THIS TIME
IS ONE AND THEN THEY'RE ALL.
RIGHT AND THERE'S NOBODY ELSE
IN THE QUEUE TO SPEAK MODERATOR.
THERE IS NOBODY ELSE AND THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT VERY GOOD THEN-
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. NVIDIA COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS GOING ONCE
GOING TWICE DID YOU HAVE A
COMMENT THAT I THINK I'M I'M
JUST WONDERING AND I THINK IF
AS WE THEIR CAR FINANCES DOES
THIS TREAT OUT OF STATE FORMED
LLC IS DEFINITELY EVAN STATE
FORMED LLCS AND I WONDER WHAT
KIND OF- WHAT ABILITIES WE HAVE
A TO BE ABLE TO TELL- OUT OF
STATE L. SEES THAT THEY HAVE TO
CONFORM BECAUSE I THINK I'D BE.
A PRETTY EASY TO BE ABLE TO
OPEN ABOUT L. C. IF THAT IF WE
DON'T HAVE AUTHORITY OVER OVER
THAT SO I MEAN I TO ANSWER NOW
BUT LIKE TO BE ABLE TO- TO DIG
IN A LITTLE MORE ON THAT LET'S
LET'S FOLLOW UP ON THAT I'M NOT
I'M NOT I DON'T I DON'T BELIEVE
WE'RE PRETTY HEALTHY
DIFFERENTLY BASED ON THE STATE
OF FILING- BUT- THAT'S JUST
ABOUT IT. OUR DID WE GET WE A
MOTION. I THINK PEOPLE ARE
FIGHTING OVER MAKING A MOTION
IF YOU DETERMINE WAS A WINNER.
OKAY I'M GOING THE MOTION BY
SEN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO AND
THE SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BENNETT. NOT NO BUT I'M JUST
WANNA MAKE A COMMENT- YOU WANNA
MAKE COMMENT. BUT WE DID HAVE A
MONITORING WENT HOW GO AHEAD
MISTER BENNETT UP AT I JUST TO
POINT TO ONE THING FOR
EVERYBODY'S BENEFIT EXPERIENCE
ACTUALLY HAD WITH THIS IN TERMS
OF L. L. C. A. N. THAT IS THAT-
IN THE STATE CONSTITUTION IT
SAYS YOU CAN'T DO AN
INITIATIVE. THAT BENEFITS
YOURSELF PERSONALLY OR A
CORPORATION. AND WE HAD A
CLEVER- GROUP OF PEOPLE THAT
FORMED AN LLC AND DID AN
INITIATIVE THAT BENEFITED
THEMSELVES AND WE WENT TO COURT
AND SAID THAT VIOLATES THE
CONSTITUTION AND THE JUDGE
INCREDIBLY SAID AN LLC IS NOT
A- CORPORATION AND NOT AN
INDIVIDUAL SO THEY WERE ALLOWED
TO CREATE AN INITIATIVE THAT
BENEFITED THEMSELVES. UP IT
CERTAINLY WAS NOT THE INTENTION
OF THE CONSTITUTION AND THAT'S
AN EXACT A AN EXAMPLE OF WHY
LLC'S YOU WE HAVE TO. MAKE THE
SPECIAL PROVISIONS FOR SO I
APPRECIATE THE F. PPC COMING
FORWARD WITH THIS- I WOULD LIKE
TO BE A CO AUTHOR OF THIS JUST
TO MEMORIALIZE MY FIGHT OVER
THIS YEAR. IN THE PAST. AND I
WILL BE BRINGING- SOME
LEGISLATION TO CLARIFY SILVA
FUTURE UDGE CAN'T MAKE THAT
RULING FORTUNATELY WE DIDN'T
APPEAL IT BECAUSE WE DIDN'T
WANT IT TO BECOME LAW- AT THE
TIME UNTIL WE HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THIS OF THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FRIDAY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT SO WE
HAVE A MOTION BY A FAMILY
MEMBER RUBIO IN A SECOND BYE.
WHO WAS THE SECOND YEAH OKAY
THAT'S GOING TO ROLE. THE
MOTION TO PASS AND RIVER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON A- FOR. HI FOR I
ARE TO. NOW SO ARE TELL NO
SENATE. SENATE I LOW HELLO MY
NAME IS. MASON NOT VOTING
MULLIN. MULLIN I WANT TO REVIEW.
WHAT THE RUBIO. FIVE TWENTY
THAT MOTION PASSES ON TO OUR TO
BILL PASSES TO THE WHAT MADE
YOU WANT TO APPROPRIATE
APPROACH. AND THAT MOVES ON TO
OUR ASSEMBLY BILL SO NINE SIR
BY THE SAME ON GOING WITH THE-
A PRESENTATION THE BILL. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND CO- AB
SOME SIX PERMANENT CALIFORNIA
NEW MOTIVO PRO TO ENSURE ITS
CONTINUED SIX AND IF. THIS A
LONG OF HOW WE TO WHERE ARE
TODAY BUT THE SHOW STORY THAT
BETTER LAW IF IMHO VOTER LAW
MORE THE TWO DECADES AGO BUT
RIGHTS HAVE IDENT ISSUE WITH
THE STATE'S IMPLEMENT OF THE
FEDERAL LAW SO DO A LAWSUIT
LEGISLATION AUTHORED BY A
COLLECTION SAY THE AND AN
ONGOING. BUT FROM THESE
CHALLENGES WE'VE SEEN
TREMENDOUS SUCCESS WHEN
CALIFORNIA LAUNCHED THE NEW
MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM IN APRIL
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN IT BECAME
THE LARGEST AND ONE OF THE
FIRST STATES TO IMPLEMENT
AUTOMATIC VOTER REGISTRATION TO
THE DMV AT ITS HEART NEW MOTOR
VOTER MADE EASIER FOR ELIGIBLE
VOTERS TO REGISTER OR UPDATE
THEIR
COMPLETING A DRIVER'S LICENSE
AND STATE IDENTIFICATION CARD
APPLICATION THE PROGRAM HAS
PLAYED AN INSTRUMENTAL ROLE IN
CLOSING VOTER REGISTRATION
GAPS. MOREOVER BY IMPROVING THE
ACCURACY OF MILLIONS OF VOTERS
MAILING ADDRESSES AND REDUCING
RELIANCE ON IN PERSON SAME DAY
VOTER REGISTRATION THE NEW
MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM PLAYED A
CRUCIAL ROLE IN INCREASING
ACCESS TO VOTE BY MAIL. BETWEEN
APRIL TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN IN
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE MORE
THAN TWELVE MILLION AT NEW OR
UPDATED VOTER REGISTRATIONS
RESULTED FROM THE NEW MOTOR
VOTER PROGRAM DESPITE THESE
SUCCESSES CHALLENGES WITH
MODERNIZING THE MOTOR VOTER
REGISTRATION PROCESS CONTINUES
TO LIMIT THE PROGRAM'S
EFFECTIVENESS AB SEVENTY SIX
WHAT APPLY LESSONS LEARNED AND
ADOPT FEDERAL MOTOR VOTER
TIMELINES FOR TIMELY
TRANSMITTAL OF VOTER
REGISTRATION INFORMATION FROM
THE DMVTO THE SECRETARY OF
STATE. AS WELL AS QUALIFYING
NUMBER OF BEST PRACTICES FROM
THE ONGOING SETTLEMENT
INCLUDING DATA REPORTING ON
PROCESSING TIMES TRADING
TRAINING OF THE DMV AND SOS
STAFF AND MAINTAINING
COORDINATORS AT THE DMV AND
SECRETARY OF STATE TO MONITOR
COMPLIANCE WITH THE FEDERAL AND%
STATE MOTOR VOTER LAWS THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THAT AB SEVENTY
SIX WILL ENSURE THAT THE
PROGRESS MADE UNDER UR NEW
MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM WILL
CONTINUE. A SYSTEM MORE THAN
THREE MILLION ELIGIBLE BUT
UNREGISTERED CALIFORNIANS TO
REGISTER TO VOTE AND KEEP.
CALIFORNIA'S VOTER ROLLS
ACCURATE AND UP TO DATE FIRST
ASK FORYOU AYE VOTE- AND WITH
US TODAY I HAVE THE- AWESOME
FOR. ON BEHALF OF THE CALL OF
CAL. CALL CAUSE. AND BRITNEY
STONECIPHER ON BEHALF OF THE C.
L. U. IF YOU'RE SOMEONE FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION WE WILL MOVE
ON TO THE PRIMARY WITNESSES AT
THIS TIME IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. I KIANA AND BRITNEY WE'LL
START WITH KIANA. GO AHEAD. YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON YOUR BERMAN AND
IN MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS JONATHAN ON FIRE AND
I'M A PROGRAM MANAGER AT
CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE THAT'S
THE FINDING OF A CO SPONSOR IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY NINE SIX
CALIFORNIA CAUSE NON OR-
FOCUSED ON BUILDING AN
INCLUSIVE DEMOCRACY AND
INFLICTED ABOUT MISSION WE
ADVOCATE POLICIES SIX ACCESS TO
THE BALLOT BOX AND CLOSE VOTER
PURGES GAP THING CAL. ALONGSIDE
OUR PART WE FOR QUALITY LIKE ON
VOTER. AND SAME DAY A AND
VOTING WILL TODAY WE ARE CAN
THE BECAUSE A REFERENCE OF THE
ALONG BY THE OTHER COACHES OF
SEVEN NINETY SIX BUT GOVERNMENT
VOTER ACCOUNT AN ACLU ACTION AB
SEVEN SIX ONE THE LO FI
BACKPACK WILL TO CALIFORNIA
MOTIVO PROGRAM WHICH LAUNCHED
AT THE THREE YEARS THE MONTH
THE PROGRAM STREAMLINED THE
REGISTER PROCESS AND AS IT MORE
THAN EVER FOR CUSTOM TO READ TO
VOTE OR UPDATE THEIR A- ONE
CONDUCT A DRIVER LICENSE ID ONE
SECOND. WELL IT'S HARD ANYTHING
HISTORY ACCORDING TO THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE 88%
OF CALIFORNIANS ELIGIBLE
POPULATION IS REGISTERED TO
VOTE DESPITE THE MAJOR ADVANCES
THAT WE'VE MADE IT MORE THAN
THREE MILLION ELIGIBLE ADULTS
IN CALIFORNIA REMAIN
UNREGISTERED A DISPROPORTIONATE
NUMBER OF THEM ARE
UNDERREPRESENTED GROUPS
INCLUDING YOUTH PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES PEOPLE OF COLOR
AND PEOPLE WITH LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENCY. IN ADDITION TO
MEETING TO CLOSE THIS GAP THE
ACCURACY OF OUR VOTER ROLLS
BECOMES INCREASINGLY IMPORTANT
AS MORE CALIFORNIANS EXPECT TO
RECEIVE THEIR BALLOTS BY MAIL
EITHER BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC
WAS THE RESULT OF MORE COUNTY.
TRANSITIONING TO THE VOTERS
CHOICE ACT. CONTINUE HERE
OVERSIGHT IMPROVEMENTS TO HELP
ARE I GO TO REGISTRATION SYSTEM
ARE NEEDED. EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY
WILL CALL THAT PRACTICES THAT
ARE CURRENTLY IN PLACE. TO
DEVELOPMENT AGREEMENT WITH THE
DMV THAT ARE SET TO EXPIRE IN
EARLY TWENTY TWENTY TWO. I
CAUGHT THANK YOU PROVISIONS OF
THIS AGREEMENT WE CAN CONTINUE
THE MOMENTUM OF OUR MOTOR VOTER
PROGRAM. AND MAKE IMPROVEMENTS
TO THE PROGRAM ALL THE TIME. WE
VENTURE BERMAN PRISONERS UPON
THIS ISSUE AND URGING I BOTH
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK
YOU. VERY MUCH. WE HAVE.
MORNING MY NAME IS PRETTY
THUMBTACKS FOR ANIMAL BUDDING
IDEA TURNEY WITH ACLU OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA IF YOU
LEAVE THE PROUD CO SPONSOR OF
SEVEN NINETY SIX I THANK THE
CHAIR FOR INTRODUCING THE BILL
OUR ORGANIZATION WORKS TO
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
DEMOCRACY IS ACCESSIBLE TO ALL
VOTERS WITH A FOCUS ON
ELIMINATING BARRIERS TO
REGISTRATION AND VOTING FOR
HISTORICALLY UNDERREPRESENTED
GROUPS. IN SERVICE OF THIS CALL
ACLU AND HER PARTNERS INCLUDING
EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY SIX CO
SPONSORS LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS
AND COMMON BECAUSE THEY SPEND
MANY YEARS ADVOCATING TO
INCREASE THE FAIRNESS AND
EFFICIENCY. THE CALIFORNIA
MOTOR VOTER SYSTEM. HERE'S THE
OTHER YES TAKE THE FORM A START
ON THE AGREEMENT THE DMV
SECRETARY STATE. OTHER BY THE
SETTLE TERM. THE N. B. IN THE
SECRETARY OF THEM PRODUCING OUR
ORGANS AT PROVIDING
ORGANIZATIONS WITH DETAILED
MONTHLY REPORTS ABOUT THE
PROCESSING AND TRANSMISSION OF
VOTER REGISTRATION APPLICATIONS
THERE THE DMB. ALONG REGULARLY
MEETING WITH US TO DISCUSS THE
CONTENTS OF THIS REPORT. THE
TRANSPARENCY ACCOUNTABILITY
MECHANISMS THAT HAVE BEEN
CREATED AT THE DMV ALLOWED
STAKEHOLDERS TO IDENTIFY AND
COLLABORATIVE BELIEVERS ALL
SYSTEMIC ISSUES THAT ARE
DELAYING THE TRANSMISSION OF
VOTER REGISTRATION APPLICATION.
THEY'VE ALSO SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPROVED CALIFORNIA COMPLIANCE
WITH STATE AND FEDERAL ELECTION
LAW. UNFORTUNATELY HOWEVER IF
THE SETTLEMENT TERMS WILL
EXPIRE IN EARLY TWENTY TWENTY
TWO AND THE NBA WILL NO LONGER
BE BOUND BY SOME OF THEIR
PAYMENTS BUT IT'S BEEN SO
pCRITICAL TO TRANSFORMING THE
MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM INTO THE
TRYING OUT THAT WE ARE
DESCRIBED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BERMAN ABOUT MY COLLEAGUES COME.
EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY SIX WILL
ENSURE THE CONTINUATION OF BEST
PRACTICES THAT ARE ALREADY IN
PLACE AT THE DMV AS A RESULT OF
THE SETTLEMENT. AND CREATE MORE
CLARITY AND CONSISTENCY ACROSS
THE NBA WORKSTREAMS. EITHER
COMMONSENSE PROVISIONS SUCH AS
REQUIRING THE DMB TO CONTINUE
TRACKING AND REPORTING VOTER
REGISTRATION PROCESSING TIME.
AND REQUIRING THE SECRETARY
ENDING BE TO TRAIN RELEVANT
STAFF AND HOW THE MOTOR VOTER
SYSTEM MARKS. MOREOVER IT BY
CLEARLY DEFINING THE TIMELINE
FOR DMB TO PROCESS MOTOR VOTER
RECORDS. EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY
SIX ONE SURE THE ELIGIBLE
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO REGISTER
DURING THE DMV TRANSACTIONS.
ARE NOT PREVENTED FROM VOTING
DURING ELECTIONS BECAUSE OF
BACKLOGS AND DID IT IN THE MAIL.
ROOM RIGHT MINISTRY DIFFERENT
TAPE. DESPITE THE ACHIEVING THE
MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM ACHIEVED.
MORE MUST BE DONE TO
PERMANENTLY SECURE THE ADVANCES
THAT HAVE BEEN DETAINED IN
RECENT YEARS. AND TO BRING A
THREE MILLION ELIGIBLE BUT
UNREGISTERED CALIFORNIA INTO
OUR DEMOCRACY. EIGHTY SEVEN
NINETY SIX THE PRACTICAL GOOD
GOVERNMENT MEASURE TO CODIFY
BEST PRACTICES AND BUILD ON THE
SUCCESS OF THE MOTOR VOTER
PROGRAM. AND REMOVE IMPEDIMENTS
EQUITABLE VOTER REGISTRATION.
THIRTY THREE FUNDS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU SO MUCH ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IT
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE THE- PRIMARY.
THE SO WE WILL NOW ON TO
DIFFERENT WORDS THAT BECAUSE
FOR ORAL TO THE THREE SEVEN
NINE THE REMINDER USE THE TIME.
DAY. ABOUT TEN MINUTES COUPLE
TIMES FORGET HELP OTHER FUNDS
ALREADY FILLED WITH ARE LIMITED
TO PROVIDE YOUR NAME THE
ORGANIZATION THAT THEY REFER
BACK. AND WHAT THEY'RE BUILT
THEY CAN IS ON THE BILL ORDER A
BOTTLE. SO WE WILL HERE IN THE
CAN ROOM THERE ANYBODY ON THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WHICH IS TO PER
THEIR BILL. ON A SO NINETY SIX.
AND THERE LOOKS LIKE ARE NONE
HERE SO WE WILL GO TO THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION. IS
THERE ANYBODY OUT THERE-
TESTIMONY STATION. THEY'RE
BEING DONE- THEN WE WILL NOW
OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WHO WISH
TO PROVIDE THEIR POSITION ON AB.
SEVEN NINE SIX R. N. JUST A
REMINDER BECAUSE I DID HAVE THE
MICROPHONE OFF WEIRD ALLOTTING
A TOTAL TIME OF TEN MINUTES.
AND WE WISH YOU WE WOULD LIKE
YOU TO STATE YOUR NAME THE
ORGANIZATION REPRESENT IF ANY.
AND WHETHER YOU SIMPLY SUPPORT
OR OPPOSE THE BILL. SO WHAT IF
WE COULD STICK TO THAT- WE
WOULD APPRECIATE IT VERY MUCH-
MODERATOR ONE TO GO AND OPEN
THE PHONE LINES. MODERATOR IS
THERE ANYBODY IN THE QUEUE TO
SPEAK ON A AB SEVENTY SIX.
MODERATOR. AND WE LOST OUR
MODERATOR. WE DO HAVE SOMEBODY
COMMENTING FROM LINE THE FORTY
FOUR. PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WHATEVER'S ONLINE
PORTAL MARC LEVINE. YEAH WE'LL
GO TO LINE ONE SEVENTY NINE.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CAN DOWN SO
THAT THEY COULD BE ON BEHALF OF
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION IN
SUPPORT. SPEAKER PLEASE. I WON
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE ROMERO WITH A CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU MA'AM
NEXT WEEK- THANK YOU. WELL I
NUMBER TWO THIRTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SEVEN ANDERSON ON BEHALF
OF SILICON VALLEY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WE HAVE ONE MORE COMING FROM
THE LINE OF THE SIXTY THREE YOU
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NUMBER SIXTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I AM
THRILLED LEGAL CARTER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA IT WOULD GO AHEAD
HELLO. YOU THERE MA'AM GO AHEAD
EITHER CARTER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA. AS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFITS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB SEVEN NINE SIX THANK YOU
THANK YOU MA'AM SORRY FOR THE
CONFUSION ARE THERE ANYBODY ANY
OTHER SPEAKERS IN THE QUEUE
FORTY FOUR OKAY SO I HAD.
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
WITH CONSTRUCTORS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE BILL CHAIR
BERMAN. THANK YOU MA'AM.
ANYBODY ELSE IN THE QUEUE. WE
WILL HAVE A THREE. SOMEBODY
KILLING UP- AND IT'LL BE JUST A
MOMENT WHEN WE GET THEM THE
LINE NUMBER. CAN ANYONE HEAR ME.
MOTOR YES GO AHEAD YEP GO AHEAD
SIR. OKAY HOW FAMILIAR I GOT MY
LINE WORKING AGAIN THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WE GO TO LINE TWO
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU DON'T DON'T ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION IN SUPPORT. AGAIN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT PETER.
THERE'S NO NOTHING TO AND
THERE'S NOBODY ELSE IF YOU WERE
GONNA BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. THE AUTHOR NOW. ALL
RIGHT WELL WE DID HAVE A YOU
WANT TO GO AHEAD AND CLOSER
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL WITH THE
U. S. JR HEY GOOD WE HAD A
MOTION BY THE LOWEST SECOND BY
RUBIO- GO AHEAD AND CALL THE
ROLL THANK YOU THE MOST NEEDS
TO PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION
BERMAN. HI BERMAN I SAILOR CHAU
NO C. R. CHAU NO BENEFITS
SENATE I LOW. LOW I MAYES. MANY
I'M MULLIN. MULLIN- I BLANCA
RUBIO. FIVE TWO ONE THANK YOU.
THAT PASSES OUT TO THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
CORRECT THANK YOU VERY. ALL OF
THE ROOM NOPE. WELL PASSED BACK
OVER TO THE CHAIR FOR THE THANK
YOU MR MEISTER- SO. THAT IS ALL
THE BILL PRESENTATIONS WE HAVE
TODAY NOW WILL RUN THROUGH THE
BILL'S TO LET PEOPLE WHO
WEREN'T HERE INITIALLY ADD ON I
BELIEVE THAT'S CORRECT THAT'S
CORRECT THAT'S CORRECT PERFECT.
SO THEN SECRETARY IF YOU WANT
TO RUN THROUGH THE BILL SO THAT
FOLKS WHO WERE. NOT HERE WHEN
THEY WERE PRESENTED TO BE ABLE
TO ADD ON. I'M GONNA START WITH
ADOPTION OF COMMITTEE ROLES- MR
LOW DID YOU WANT TO ADD ON. I
MISTER MASON MISTER MULLIN.
FIVE MANY ROLES THANK YOU. JUST
SO WE KNOW. THEY'RE BOTH ON THE
MIKE WHEN YOU GO THROUGH WHEN
YOU'RE TWENTY AFTER THE NUMBER
CAN YOU SAY WHAT OKAY. ON
CONSENT CAL- LOW FI LOW AYE
MAYES. HI MAYES AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN I THANK YOU FOR. ITEM
ONE AB FORTY LORENA GONZALEZ
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR WAS
VOTING I. MR MAYS. MAYES HAS
NOT VOTING MULLIN MULLIN I.
LIKELY NOT. OKAY LIKE NOT. ON
ITEM FOR AB EIGHT SEVEN ONE
KILEY WE DO NOT HAVE A MOTION
OR SECONDS. ANYBODY THAT BILL
DIES FOR LACK OF A MOTION FOR A
SECOND. THANK YOU. AB FIFTY
THREE LOW THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
THE CHAIR IS BUILDING I MAYES.
MAYES NOT VOTING MULLIN MULLIN
I. AND THE LAST REMAINING ITEM
WAS ITEM TWELVE EIGHTY SEVEN
NINETY SIX BERMAN TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION THE CHAIR VOTING
I. BLANCA RUBIO. NUMBER. WHY
DON'T WE CLOSE CLOSE THE ROLE
LET'S CLOSE THE ROLE. OKAY OKAY
DOES IT THAT IT'S OKAY SO THE
MEETING IS ADJOURNED THANK YOU
EVERYBODY.